Woo... Woo... Woo... Woo...
Five!
Yippee!
Hello, hello, hello!
Everybody!
Welcome back to Devil May Cry!
Hello, hello, hello!
Yes, today, I'm back.
Last week, I did not play so much of Devil May Cry 5.
But today, I would like to play more.
How it goes.
You mentioned watching...
Oh, hold on.
Wait, what's happening?
Wait, why is it so fast?
Why is it so soon?
IGN has a great series of devs watching speedruns.
That includes 5 and Portal.
Or, uh, DMC5 and Portal.
Woo!
I...
Saw something like that.
I don't remember which game it was.
Where the devs were watching someone...
It was like, just the other day that I saw it too.
But yeah.
So...
That's all.
2B's Brian, welcome back!
Oh, there's a Mento's running through my head!
Barley, welcome back!
Thank you, Yuni!
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
And Nicholas, welcome back!
From C to SS, how was your day?
Oh!
Oh, are we super stylish today?
I don't think I'm ever super stylish any day.
Or sexy smokey...
Stop!
Oh my god!
Go!
Stop!
Let me speak, please!
Yay!
D and SSS not included.
Now...
No D!
Uh...
Today...
I...
I think I'm A for awesome.
Probably.
Yeah, probably.
My birthday was two days ago.
I wanted a wish, but my bank froze my account!
Green bear, are you okay?
You don't have to send the super chat.
But happy birthday!
Let's just pretend it's two days ago.
Happy, happy birthday, green bear!
Yeah!
Um...
Yeah, I didn't stream yesterday.
Oh, yesterday was my birthday!
Spice night!
Happy birthday!
I re...
Wait, oh gosh.
Hold on.
Oh, there we go.
I request your best...
G...
Stare with your cat eyes.
Oh.
Sure, I could try.
G...
Yeah, happy birthday!
Spice night!
Happy birthday!
Wacky Wahoo Pizza Fun!
Thank you!
I just arrived in Japan yesterday.
Have fun, Vijay!
Oh!
Good luck, Vijay!
Participating in a big card game tournament.
Let's go!
Um...
I'm gonna...
Practice...
In...
The...
Void...
Before we...
Get into...
The game.
Because I...
Want...
We only are on mission 3.
I need to...
Remember how to play the game.
Last time we...
Beat up that big guy boss.
Oh.
I think we should split into two groups.
And cover more ground.
Good idea.
Oh!
Thank you for the raid!
I'm sorry I didn't see who.
Thank you.
Cash first.
All the materials I collected for your little...
Oh, we watched this one last time.
But that's okay.
My brilliant badass work is worth every dime.
And you know it.
Well, your quality control sucks ass.
And you know that.
Or maybe don't let the demon smack you around so much.
Whatever.
She makes a double cry.
Five.
Thank you.
I am truly gifted.
It's a work of art.
Oh, so you're an artist now, huh?
Yes I am.
Got any questions with chicken?
I like her.
She's so snappy.
My grandmother...
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
She's her freckles are so stinking cute.
Yeah!
Cook that bird!
Any more questions?
Huh?
Little cheeky?
V.
I'll take my leave now.
Who is this old man on her?
As a tattoo?
I'll see you at the bottom of the Klyphoth.
Klyphoth.
This is the hardest word to say ever.
That's the real reason he's a villain.
I gotta shake the cobwebs out.
I'll let you know.
Hey, you got any more questions?
Better ask it now.
I can't read minds.
Ooh, well, yeah.
Yeah, we got our new arms.
That's right.
We got our new arms!
Okay.
Let's go to customize.
Because I got new arms.
I need to go into the void.
And I need to remember how to use things.
So...
Wait.
Um...
Let's just, uh...
Let's just...
Try.
Let's just try and...
It's fine.
Let's just try.
Oh, gosh.
I forgot how ugly the things are in this game.
Get away from me.
Hold on.
I gotta adjust audio too.
Save for the cover.
Thank you!
Oh.
Okay.
Uh...
And then...
This one?
Okay.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Jump time.
Oh, yeah!
Wait.
Oh, no.
Hold on.
I remember.
No, no, no.
Hold on.
Come on!
I can do this!
Right now!
Ah!
We have to...
We got it!
Oh!
The way he sidesteps is too...
Wait.
Hold on.
I gotta get him in the right...
Ha!
Huh!
Yeah!
OK.
And then...
For the arms, you can...
Hold down...
And...
Oh, wow, that was such a way.
Okay, got it.
Cool.
That's the devil trigger dance.
Devil trigger.
Bang, bang, bang.
Pull my devil trigger.
Okay, and then this one.
What does it do also?
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
It does the push.
Oh, I forgot to get the other one though.
Hold on.
And then if I...
Yeah.
Oh, and shoot.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
That one is the bomb.
She's the bomb.
Let go of lock on.
Wait, so I shouldn't lock on while I...
There's two different aren't there?
If you... If you...
Lock on, and don't lock on.
Yeah, hold B breaks the arm.
Yes, yes, yes.
Hold on, let's see.
Oh, that's right!
And then I can call it back for this one.
And then... Can I ride it?
Or am I crazy?
How do I ride it?
Hold circle?
Oh, I'm on Xbox type controller.
Wait, hold on.
If I...
Hold B when it's coming back.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, there we go!
And then...
Oh, hold on.
It's a little tight.
Wait, hold on.
Redo.
Hold on.
Wait, wait.
And then I can do that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
My friend, Jonathan, is watching while sleepy.
He said he'd go to sleep if you told him to.
Also, it's his birthday.
Jonathan, happy birthday!
Go to sleep.
What are you doing?
If you're sleepy, you should go to sleep.
What the heck are you doing?
Hmm?
Wait, um...
Wait.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, uh...
Wait, hold on.
How long does it last for?
Oh, it just comes back.
Wait.
Does it always just come back?
Oh, it does.
I thought it was gonna break.
Like, how do I...
Oh, is the lock-on the one that's gonna break it?
No?
Let's just call...
Oh, I guess if you skate?
Or...
Oh, this one.
That one will break it.
Got it.
So...
Come here.
So this is the push.
The push, push, push.
Okay.
Okay, so it's like...
Come here and push.
Come here.
You can like...
You can really play with them here.
You can really...
Lightning Hand does a pretty big chunk of damage.
Look at this guy!
Look at his face!
He's so bloody!
Are you okay?
You okay?
And then we also...
I can charge my gun now.
You okay?
Yeah, get up.
Get up, get up, get up.
Okay.
And then...
Let's...
Let's get rid of this one.
Happy birthday!
Now make a win!
Explode...
Helter Skelter...
Is like...
Oh my god!
But if I...
If I hold it down...
Let's do that...
Okay.
And then Gubra...
Sorry, I'm just trying to remember what each one does.
Whoa!
Can I like...
But I can...
So if I just...
If I don't move, it does that.
But if I'm moving...
I see, I see, I see.
Okay.
It's Nero's trickster.
Are you okay immediately?
Slash his face.
And then...
This one...
Oh, this one does the beam!
But it does a...
It does a different beam in the air, no?
Hold on.
Yeah!
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Crazy, crazy.
Thank you, man, and everyone for the birthday wishes.
I can rest peacefully now, Jonathan.
Goodnight.
Goodnight, goodnight.
Okay.
I think I'm...
Alright to just...
Go.
I'll try.
Nothing...
Nothing better than just getting into the middle of it, you know?
To...
To attempt.
I think I bought everything that...
Wait.
Let's make sure I bought everything.
Skills!
Ah...
I want to wire snatch...
Four...
Thousand...
Forty thousand.
Oh...
Blue Rose...
That's our gun.
Maybe I save for streak too?
I don't remember what I was saving for.
Oh, wait.
Split might be...
Left stick back.
Wire snatch 40k.
Split is good.
Let me...
Try it.
Let me try it.
I forgot!
We...
We don't get...
Um...
What's the words?
Uh...
Refunge!
I fear that I would probably be like...
You know, like that, but...
Oh...
See?
Mm...
I'm...
I'm pressing back!
Oh...
Wait...
Hold on...
Oh...
That's the one I was thinking of.
Okay, okay...
If I do this...
Oh...
Wait, can I...
Hold on...
I'm...
Back according to you.
I was...
I was just...
I'm just...
You know...
Hold on...
Wait...
If I...
No, hold on...
Oh...
If I... Aha!
Now, see, the thing is, I have to, like, be able to, like, properly execute these things, you know?
Up and down.
I gotta properly execute them.
When I'm not... And also, I make him go so far.
Okay, okay.
So, hold on.
Um... Oh, wait.
Oh, oops.
Wait, okay, hold on, hold on.
Come here.
Oh, and jump.
Oh, I was late.
I was late.
Hold on.
Oh, but I've sent him flying too far.
Well, I can try it.
Hold Y while the combo?
Hold?
Hold Y when knocking him up.
Ew.
What do you think I'm doing to this guy?
What do you think I'm doing to him?
Oh, that's right!
Oh.
Hey, hey, hold on.
Hold on.
Wait.
Nope.
I will... I will get it, though.
I think I'll still use it.
I will get it.
12 months!
How's our gangster ghost fit?
Let me... Okay, I should explain, huh?
Oh my gosh, you guys!
You guys, I...
Yesterday, I was like... I was like feeling like I wanted a donut.
You know, I was like, I want a donut!
I don't know.
I just was craving a donut.
And I hadn't had a donut in a while, so I was like, I'm gonna go get a donut.
But I didn't know what kind of donut, so I posted on Twitter.
I was like, what kind of donut should I get?
People... A lot of people were like, mochi donuts.
And I was like, oh!
There's like... There's like a mochi donut place that I've only been to...
I think like once by me.
So I was like, okay!
I will go get a mochi donut.
Um...
And...
Which has gotten more chuckle out of you?
The time has come and so have I, or it's getting bigger.
I definitely think the time has come and so has I.
So have I.
It has made me laugh quite a bit.
Thanks for the super chat!
And so I was like, I want a mochi donut because...
Um...
I've only been to the one place and I haven't had it in a long time.
So...
I went...
And I got a drink with my donut.
And...
The guy...
It was not...
Busy.
In the cafe.
But he made it seem like he was doing a lot of stuff.
So...
I was like, I'll get a donut and a drink please.
And he said, okay.
And he...
I paid.
And then he gave me my drink a couple minutes later.
And I'm sitting there and I was like...
Well, he probably would have given me my donut...
When I first ordered the donut.
And so...
I was like...
Yeah, just one donut.
Just a single donut.
And...
I'm like...
Hmm...
Well...
Maybe once I get my drink, he'll give me the donut.
And I get my drink and he doesn't give me the donut.
And I'm like...
Hmm...
But I also didn't...
He didn't say which...
He didn't ask like, which donut do you want?
And I was like...
Um...
So I was like...
Well...
Not all the donuts had labels on them.
So I was gonna ask him.
And so I'm like sitting there.
And he's like, some people come in, some people leave.
You know, not very busy.
Just like, literally, I think like two people came in.
So I was like, okay, well.
And then they left.
So I was like, okay, well, um, I'll just, uh... And I'm sitting there.
I'm sitting there.
And I was like, it's been, at this point, it's been so long that I feel awkward going up to him and being like, Hey, by the way, I also got a donut.
And so I was like, I missed my window of opportunity where it would have been acceptable to ask about my donut.
You know what I mean?
And so I'm sitting there and I'm like, oh, I should probably go up.
And I was like, I was like, okay, finally.
I was like, okay, I'll just go up.
And there's a girl also that has been in the cafe.
And I'm sitting there, or rather, I'm standing there waiting for the guy to come back.
And she's like, do you need help?
And I was like, oh, I was going to ask about the donuts, what other kinds there were.
And she was like, oh, that's my boyfriend.
I'll get his attention.
And so she did.
And he comes up and he's like, oh, yeah, did you need something?
And I was like, oh, I wanted to ask about what kind of donuts these were.
And he told me.
And I was like, oh, cool.
Can I get this one?
And then he's like, yeah, sure.
And then he starts ringing me up.
And I'm like, oh, no.
He forgot that I previously paid for the donut.
But then I was doubting myself because I didn't get a receipt.
That's why I was like doubting myself.
I was like, maybe how much tip did I put on?
I don't remember.
Maybe my drink plus the tip was this amount.
So he didn't actually hear me the first time.
And I did pay.
I don't know.
And so he rings me up.
And I'm like getting my card ready.
And then he goes, wait a second.
Didn't you pay?
And I was like, or he was like, didn't you ask for a donut earlier?
And I was like, yeah, yeah, I think so.
I forgot.
It's like a defense mechanism.
And then he goes, oh, yeah, my bad.
And I was like, oh, thanks.
He gave you an owl.
I know.
And then I got my donut and it wasn't very good.
It was fine.
It was good.
It was just like, didn't have as much flavor as I thought it would.
Oh.
But I said I forgot, even though I didn't actually forget.
Because I was sitting there being like, oh, I got a donut with my thing.
But he forgot about my donut.
But I just said it as a defense mechanism to be like, so not...
I was like, in my brain, I'm like, oh, if I say I forgot, that's like nonchalant, right?
Like, oh, yeah, yeah, I totally...
Oh, oh, I got a donut.
Oh, oh, God.
Oh, God.
So I can never...
I can never haunt that location ever again.
Luckily, it's not my own cafe.
Totally nonchalant.
Yeah, I'll never go back.
Not because...
Sorry, I'm crying, so I'm wiping my tears.
Not because the donut was bad, but because...
Because, um... But because I fear I was way too awkward to ever go back.
But the guy was nice.
The guy was nice.
I just... So it wasn't his fault.
Well, I guess it was his fault for forgetting.
It's also my fault for not saying anything.
Boston cream for next time?
Yeah, I'm gonna get Boston cream next time.
And find a different mochi donut place.
I'm baking cookies right now.
You want them thick and soft or thin and crispy.
Thick and soft!
Oh, wait, but I like the edges to be crispy.
Does anyone else like their cookies like that?
Where like the... You know when you take them right out of the oven and you give it just a little bit of time.
So where the edges become nice and crispy.
But then the inside is still really warm and soft.
That's the best.
That's the best, baby.
Okay, what was I playing?
I don't think I have any more that I can pay.
Or rather, you know, I don't think I can...
I kind of want to switch.
Oh wait, I haven't even edited my magazine.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, how do I...
How do I...
Speaking of switch, did you guys get the switch?
Wait, why can't I put it in?
Oh, I already did.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you're right.
It says magazine.
Sorry.
I want to do this one.
Wait.
But rocket punch.
Maybe I'll do rocket punch.
Waiting for more games.
Tomodachi Life 2.
Hi, Mint.
I'm at a convention.
Is it cool if I publicly broadcast your embarrassing donut stories?
No!
Don't!
I don't want the world!
Also, you guys, I get a gorb.
There's login bonuses.
Oh my gosh, I forgot how terrifying the blorb is.
I got a gorb as a login bonus, so...
Maybe I should just log in every day that I'm not...
Or, like, open up the game every day even if I'm not streaming it.
Not until it doesn't eat up a college tuition to buy.
That's fair.
I love that you explained the whole donut story and never explained how gangster relates to it.
Oh!
Vivicor, thank you for the 5-gifted.
So, I...
Okay.
I used to use the Google keyboard.
I don't remember.
G-board or whatever.
And I was like...
I don't know.
It's...
Okay.
I switched back to my...
I have a...
Samsung Galaxy.
And I switched back to the Galaxy...
Like, the Samsung keyboard because...
I felt that, like, the Google keyboard became so bloated with stuff.
I was like, there's just so much here that I don't care about.
And...
Which is so ironic because you...
Samsung phones are known for their bloatware.
And so...
But the keyboard is pretty clean.
Actually.
So...
Um...
I feel...
Yeah.
It does have a lot.
It does!
Google keeps messing with UI.
I know!
It's so annoying.
Shift key.
I've never tried that before.
Hold on.
Let me write it down.
Shift key.
I'll look into it.
But I also have, like, a custom...
Uh...
What's the word?
Custom...
Theme for my phone.
And so the keyboard now matches the theme.
But the...
But the autocorrect on it is...
Is so bad.
Oh, Swift!
Sorry.
Thank you.
Swift key.
The autocorrect is so bad.
And I taught...
Tried typing...
Having...
Like...
Or...
I haven't.
No.
Because I was writing.
I haven't had a mochi donut in a long time.
And instead of haven't...
It changed it to gangster.
Swift key.
I'll try it out.
Gangster donut.
So now I'm...
Gangster.
Yo, yo, yo.
I'm...
Gangster donut.
That's my...
That's my gangster name.
Donut.
Wait.
Gangster donut.
Yo, yo, yo.
A gangster ever heard of autocorrecting something?
I don't know.
And I...
I'm sorry, guys.
I just...
I just send...
I don't read...
Read my tweets.
But like 90% of the time...
I only reread messages if it's something important.
Like if I'm...
Like if it's a...
Like a business message or something.
My favorite was...
I will go, go, go donut.
Yeah.
I went, went, went donut.
And I was sad, sad, sad.
Gangster donut is your...
Metal Gear Cone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, guys.
Anyway.
Okay.
Xseed is...
My...
Vroom, vroom.
What is breaker plus?
Oh, it just allows me to have another...
Okay.
We got to save up some roars.
People asking if Mito can turn off autocorrect.
And I'm curious if they know what happened last time.
Yeah.
I've done that before.
And it's not a pretty sight.
Me without autocorrect.
Especially because I don't...
Check my tweets.
My messages.
I just send.
Okay.
Flying hunter.
All right.
We're going to try the red punch.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Nero, you should not be driving around with your feet on the dashboard.
That is so dangerous.
If you get into a car accident, you're basically screwed.
Time to forget everything.
Yeah, maybe.
It's not that I forget things.
Sometimes I forget.
It's mostly that I panic.
Autobots.
One guy managed to beat this game on hardest difficulty without using weapons.
So there isn't really a wrong way to play as long as you win.
So much for teamwork.
Nice.
Niko's cute.
She can get away with it.
What the heck is that?
When he said gangster donut, my mom went to mint walking into a donut shop.
A friend for the mafia.
Wirebound.
Standing on platforms lit with red flames.
When no enemies are around, will turn the flames blue and cause grip points to appear in the air.
Are there any enemies around?
Hi, Niko!
I guess not.
It's quiet.
Lock onto grim...
Oh, I thought they meant like point...
I was like, what the heck is a grim grip point?
Like, what are those points?
I thought it meant like...
Like, you know...
Like, points.
Like a score.
Uh...
Okay.
Yeah, we know how to do this.
Wait, so there's really nothing else around here?
Hold on.
Hold on, before we move onward.
What if I...
What if I take a little dip?
Thanks, Niko!
Okay, bye.
All right.
Just Niko dialogue.
I didn't forget people telling me to explore a little bit more in this game.
Hi, Robot!
We gotta...
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Oh my god.
Oh, ouch!
Wait.
No.
Stop.
Oh, there we go.
Woo!
How are you supposed to combo while it's doing that?
Can you still attack with the sword while it's...
While it's punching him?
Oh.
You can!
That's so funny.
What else is around here?
Oh, another...
Grippy...
Grippy grip...
Grabby grub.
All right.
I'm gripping.
Oh, I'm not gripping.
My grippers...
Shoo!
Did you forget you can wire grab enemies?
Maybe?
I don't know.
Shut up!
Stop it!
I just started playing!
Punch?
Oh, okay.
I was like, what the heck is this?
I thought it was an invisible wall for a second.
Roll...
Leave that sweet, sweet money.
Oh!
Secret blur...
Blurb!
This thing is so ugly.
Oh, God!
It's so scary!
I don't like him.
Nasty!
Blurb!
Yay, blurb!
Yeah.
Wait, was there a... Was there a spot that... Oh, what's that over there?
Wait, how do I... How do I get to the massive RORB?
Wait.
Tons of RORB.
How do I get to there?
So rude to him.
He can't... He has no feelings.
Jump pad, but where?
Why is the music so like... It's kinda cute.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, sorry.
I'm probably making... I'm making myself dizzy.
Wee!
And then I'm gonna attack you too.
Baby.
Oh my god.
Oh, where the hell did you come from?
Oh!
Ouch.
Helter Skelter.
Oh.
Oh no, I broke it.
Wait, when did I break it?
Why am I on Helter Skelter?
Where's all my things at?
Happy birthday!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Nice.
Got him.
How did I break it?
They break when you get hit.
while they're in use.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Good to know.
I thought it only broke if you held down the beat.
Can I go back to the... Oh no!
My red punch!
But also... I went through two!
I didn't even... I went through two arms and I didn't even notice.
Oh, hold on.
Uh... Blalalalalalalalalala.
Uh, villain!
Happy birthday!
Not to take away from wacky woohoo.
But my niece thinks you're very pretty.
And tried to wave hi at you.
Hello!
Oh!
Can I get a birthday for Ellie?
Happy birthday, Ellie!
Happy birthday!
Hello, hello!
Sorry that I was punching things.
Zero, welcome to membership.
Blorb looks like it's having a flashback.
Of being called funny name when it was a child Blorb.
It looks like it sees all.
Like its brain is just...
Seeing everything.
Okay...
I want to get over there.
I have to figure out how to get over there.
What is this puzzle?
Oh!
Oh, it's the nasties!
Um...
Wait, I hear somebody!
I heard...
Oh!
Hi, V!
He's like, it's my turn now!
Hahaha!
Everyone was wishing her a happy birthday.
What?
What are you talking about?
I mean...
Yeah, I saw that.
Oh, there was a...
Maybe I can go back.
Which way?
Oh!
This one goes...
What's happening?
What is going on?
What are you doing over there, mister?
This game is making me all over the place.
Wait...
Oh, I can grab it now!
Nice!
Okay.
Yeah!
She was a little busy.
I saw...
Sorry, I can't wish people a happy birthday always immediately.
Don't say I'm late though.
I think late would be...
If I'm like...
You know...
Completely...
A different day.
Let's see.
Let's go back.
How do I get over to the big...
I know it's hard to believe, but I'm playing a video game.
It might be hard to believe, but...
I am...
Playing a game.
Trying to pay attention to it.
Trying...
Is the key word.
I'm trying...
I've heard it's an attempt.
Wait!
Maybe it's off the side of the building too.
Hold on...
I really want all those roars!
Oh no, there's nothing.
Hmm...
No, no, no, no, no, no...
No, no, no, no, no...
Over there?
Maybe?
Oh, I...
Yeah, okay.
I think I just gotta...
Continue onward.
It's actually impressive that you notice as many as you do.
Especially when the timing is off.
Screw it.
We're taking this fucking thing down.
Wow!
Uh, mister...
Uh, there's a three-year-old watching.
Please, watch your language, Nero!
Um...
Well, you know, if someone's...
Sending me money...
I feel horrible if I...
Don't read...
A message, you know?
I...
You know...
Very much appreciate it.
You know, so...
Minky is never early or late.
I freak...
When I freak, it is with...
The right time.
Attacking certain spots.
What am I attacking?
Right there?
Oh!
Ah!
Hold your horses.
So that way will probably lead to over there.
Yes.
That makes sense.
And then...
Let's get this one over here as well.
What's in the water?
Can I grab this?
Nice.
Ay!
I don't remember how...
I think I...
I know I can get rid of these.
Ah!
I got it!
Ay!
I may not have bought the Gabriel Subsperge other than the Tech Deck.
Oh!
Oh no!
Wait!
Not a problem!
Thank you!
Oh, these guys are...
Oh, hello?
These guys...
These guys are like babies.
They are not strong at all.
Oh!
So now...
We go back...
And we go attack this guy...
To get upstairs.
Oh!
Okay.
Come back.
Come back!
Wait!
Where'd he go?
Wait, did I miss my chance?
Oh no, he's there.
Okay.
Oh!
My bad.
What?
That was too late again.
Cause I'm...
Stupid.
Alright.
Oh!
Why can't I...
Why can't I jump...
In...
The air?
Speaking of horses, Umamusume release day has been announced.
Oh, really?
Already?
Oh my gosh.
I predicted that too.
I think like...
The other day, I was talking about Umamusume Global.
Wait for it to fly up.
I'm too early.
Oh!
My bad.
I
thought...
My brain was like...
It would...
Um...
Oh hi!
Is uh...
It...
It would stop...
Hey!
Come here!
Oh my...
Please!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Lots of big butts!
Oh yeah!
Wait...
Oh!
KDI!
Missed her...
Hold on...
Random gorg...
Where do you think you're going, eh, buddy?
More butts, please!
Where's the rest of the butts?
Oh, did I miss them?
Aw man...
Oh well...
Okay...
I see a grueler...
They ran away...
Cowards!
All of them...
I lost all my savings on...
Cyan and horserace does!
That's just how it goes...
Thinking about his girl mid-combo...
Wait...
Where is it?
Oh, I'm not on top of it...
I'm sorry...
The mother of...
Oh!
Omelettes!
Wow!
How much did we get from that?
Wait...
What do you mean out of time?
Hmm?
So close?
Would it like explode?
Or something?
It oxidized...
Oh...
So there's time limit...
There's a tiny amount left...
Oh...
It's okay!
And then we go here...
Okay...
That should be good...
I think we got everything in this area...
So...
Now we can continue...
Onward!
Another...
They're handing...
Gorbs out like...
They're handing gorbs out like candy!
Ordered the mini...
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
The mini...
Tech Tech...
I saw someone say that it was like...
The perfect size for...
Chippy Minto...
Or...
Minto plushie...
I agree...
Get her some tiny glasses...
Some tiny sunglasses...
She'll look so cool...
Who's here?
Nobody?
It's so quiet!
Quiet...
Why is it so quiet in this part?
Oh...
Spooky...
Demon tree blood clots...
Some demon tree roots contain clots of blood...
That's so gross!
Destroy these clots to get red orbs...
Destroying the clots sometimes open up new paths...
Or trigger something in the environment...
Oh...
Nasty...
Holy cow...
We've gotten...
So much money...
Punchline...
I wish to obtain you...
This game is very generous with money...
Ha ha ha...
Oh...
Who am I fighting?
Oh, these guys...
Out of the way!
Oh...
Come on...
Come here, come here...
Where did the other guy go?
Come here...
Hehehe...
Easy peasy...
Just...
Let's just say you'll need that many...
Gorbs eventually...
Okay...
I believe it...
I'll try not to waste them willy-nilly for now...
Hehehe...
You know...
Nice...
Wow...
This is so...
This is so beautiful though...
It's a little archway...
Take Kirie here...
So romantic...
Gotta savor the gorb...
Yummy...
Sorry...
I'm still...
I don't know why...
I'm adjusting to the camera...
Cause it's a little...
Hyperactive...
Okay...
We gotta go get the other one now...
A sewer date...
She would be...
The best smelling thing there...
Come here...
Oh...
Wait...
Come here...
Are you...
I can't...
I can't get this guy...
Come here...
Where's everybody else...
Oh there you are...
I forgot to go up with you...
Oh...
Where's everybody else...
Music's over...
I'll get used to everything again...
Eventually...
Just give me a little bit of time guys...
Especially since I didn't play the game very much last time...
But I'll get...
I'll get back into it...
Eventually...
This looks explodable...
Woah...
Hey...
It pays to be observant...
Oh... Hi Nero...
Sorry...
I was looking behind you...
Anything in here too?
TDA?
Oh...
What the?
Where?
Who are you?
Oh...
Yeah...
Run away!
Oh, come here?
Run away?
Come here?
Dodge.
I don't think I.
Wait, wait.
Woo!
Hi, John.
Yeah.
Come here.
Oh.
Stay away!
Get over here.
Nice parry.
Thank you!
Nice.
Alright, stinkos.
What's in here?
Explosions.
Explosives?
Am I supposed to blow that up?
Will I die?
Maybe there's a guy from the science team in the dumpster.
Yeah.
Most likely, right?
I'm scared of touching this.
Will it blow up?
Can I get an MGS birthday for our blue boy in the chat?
I'm not... Well, I guess it's not a traditional birthday song.
I'm not doing birthday songs at the moment just because my voice has been...
very rough lately.
But I can probably do a Metal Gear one because it's not so sing-songy.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Blue boy, happy birthday!
Yeah.
Sorry, guys.
I have to hold off.
Probably for... I'm gonna try blowing it up.
Okay, never mind.
Probably for like the next couple of months since I'm...
Uh... Yeah.
But birthday songs will return eventually.
Thank you and apologies.
No, no need to apologize.
Meow!
Oh, this guy again?
Oh!
I did blow it up this time!
Wait.
Ah, there we go.
The way I was...
There we go.
Get away from me!
You crazy?
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
I'm not realizing what face...
the way I'm facing.
So I'm trying to do the combo.
Like that.
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Come here.
Ooh!
Did not parry that one.
Ouch!
Oh!
Oh, there's more!
Oh.
Where did you come from?
Let's go!
Yeah!
You know what?
Screw this!
Yeah!
This guy scares me.
Whoo!
Yeah!
Ha ha haa!
That guy scares me.
I knew we would be able to use that.
Wait, did I see something here?
I saw something glow in... my imagination.
I'm delusional.
Hi from Level Up Cod.
I'm browsing the dealer's room.
Thank you, Agent.
I'll be having fun.
And then there was... I saw... I thought I saw a little thingy.
It's a grabby-grab, but maybe not.
Oh, there it is.
I did.
I'm not completely delusional.
Okay, there's a hole up there, but they're totally ignoring the flashing blue light that indicates...
Potentially... a bilarb fragment.
Take it.
There we go.
Nice.
Anything underneath the stairs?
Nope.
Potential blower fragment within our vicinity?
Again, sorry.
If the camera makes you dizzy, it's making me a little bit dizzy.
Wait.
Not yet.
What is it?
There we go.
Easy.
Good.
There we go.
Where is it?
Wah!
Hot blorbs in their area.
She was smoking.
Sexy style.
Okay.
Nero.
It's so embarrassing.
Oh, that's not where the hole is.
Oh my gosh.
That's where the hole is.
Why is it showing me how many arms I got?
Oh.
Whoa!
Hot blower?
No way.
I'm going to cry.
No!
Please just leave.
Oh.
Yeah, exactly.
Just leave.
Okay.
Nice.
Please just leave.
I don't want to deal with you.
Whoa.
Oh, yeah.
I hate books.
I hate learning.
Goodbye, books.
Hate books.
Libraries, be gone.
Uh...
What is...
Okay.
So we just...
Hate tables.
And books.
Nobody should ever learn in this room ever again.
Wow, I really just...
Destroyed everything in here.
Paintings are fine.
That is art.
Oh.
I'm going to cry.
Oh, God.
I'm GS2 style.
Stop parrying me, please.
You bastard.
Stop it!
Please!
A second one!
I'm going to kill you.
I'm going to kill you, actually.
I'm going to kill the game.
Oh, golly.
Please!
Just get me out of here.
They're not nearly as bad as before, I guess.
Oh.
Give me your...
Give me your pieces of your body.
I hate busts!
Of the stone variety.
Oh, my God.
You can really just tear this place apart!
Aw.
Why does the music feel so whimsical?
Blah!
Old men!
Oh.
Are okay.
No books!
No learning!
Close the schools!
Hey, thanks!
Yikes!
Oh!
So funny!
This game is so silly!
Oh!
Nice!
Punchline!
Weeeee!
Oh!
Look at that!
Dang it.
Platforming.
There will be an attempt.
Maybe I can just get...
Wait.
Maybe I can just get that one.
You know?
Maybe I don't have to go through the whole platforming sequence.
Maybe I can just...
Be good.
Okay.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
That's it.
Mm-hmm.
Aha!
Yahoo!
My double trigger.
Where are we?
Oh!
You can air taunt as your double job.
You can?
Right now!
Oh, I guess so.
Oh my gosh!
I've been forgetting to do this this entire time, huh?
What the...
Oh!
Wow!
Beautiful!
Hope my girlfriend's doing well.
Without strength, I can't protect anything.
I know that.
This way.
Phone.
No books means no Mothman nor Lich Lord, Mito.
I...
You're really making it sound like that's a bad thing?
Was that a bad thing?
Let's get at one.
There we go.
Wait.
That's right!
I can call her!
We can call Niko.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
You're up, Niko.
Come on in.
How's she gonna get in you?
Oh my god!
No, I got you covered, asshole.
Damn!
Okay!
Let me in.
There's the other...
Oh, there we go.
Customize.
Yo!
You just here to window shop?
We got so much money now.
What should we get?
I'll just grab it.
Huh.
I could keep saving up for a wire snatch three.
Oh.
Table hopper's worth it.
Is it really?
I never use it in the other games, so...
All on the ground just before an attack.
Press Rb.
Horizontally.
A.
Or, wait.
Wait, I'm not thinking of... I'm thinking of enemy step.
I'm not thinking of... table hopper.
Is this not a dodge?
It's a really good dodge.
Oh, but I can't because it's right before an attack.
Wait, hold on.
I know I can do it in the set... Wait, is it in enemy settings?
Here we go, okay.
Enemy action on.
Oh, wow!
I can change what enemy... Wait, enemy damage.
You know what?
On.
On for both.
So I can practice.
You can change what enemy it is!
I will... I will cry.
I will cry.
Let's just stick it to the normal guy.
And... attack.
Attack.
Oh.
And...
You gonna attack?
Attack.
Oh wait, no.
You're slow.
Attack!
Am I doing it?
Did I... Was that it?
Haline.
The stinger from...
Air to ground.
Too early.
No.
It's frame perfect?
Oh, I will never get it then.
Am I still too early?
Ah!
I see, I see, I see.
I see.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Chill out.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
It's gotta be so...
Perfect.
The timing is not that strict.
Well, clearly it is!
Hahaha!
Okay, I think I'm...
See, even when he's swinging!
Even when he's coming down!
How am I too early?
Really?
Wow.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
I don't think I'll get it.
I mean, it might be useful to have.
Because if I...
Oh, that one.
That one, obviously.
It might be useful to have just to have.
I mean, it doesn't hurt to have, you know?
Stinger is useless and dumb.
Made by Payline and Joy.
Very cute.
What do you mean?
It's extra iframes.
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
Come here.
Oh, wait.
Ouch, ouch.
Let me try it.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, whoop, whoop.
Oh, hold on.
Let me try with a different enemy, maybe.
I hate myself, so...
Scary.
I'm like in this...
Oh, okay.
I gotta also learn when his timing is too.
Exposure therapy.
Exactly.
Oh, I...
Oh!
That was good.
That one was way too early.
I could tell.
Ah!
See, I can tell when it's like...
It does the shine, you know?
The little...
Shrink.
Oh!
Oopsie.
My gosh.
Hello?
Like I said, it's cheap, and I don't think it hurts to...
Have it.
It's cheap, but I don't think it hurts to have it.
So...
Yeah, I'll grab it.
Why not?
Six frame window.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's leave.
Mmm.
Doesn't hurt.
I can only get better at it.
Maybe.
And it's...
Like I said, it's so cheap.
Learn it.
Personally, I would buy the rest of the exceed levels.
Some attacks can change when you're on exceed level 3 rather than level 1.
How much are they?
I can only buy exceed level 2.
I just have to remember to...
To use exceed.
I have to remember to use it.
3K...
Bad.
No, no.
Now there's also the gun upgrade.
Which I have...
Is this...
This is just to...
Yeah, fill it up.
Fire 3 shots.
Can I only get 2 though?
Ah, there it is.
Level...
Color up 3.
Okay, okay.
I don't think it hurts to have that either.
Streak 2!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, there's pay line.
Is this what you guys are talking about?
I don't have enough.
Okay, we'll...
We'll get more money.
Pay line.
On the ground.
RB.
Back.
Oh, RB.
LS.
Back to forward.
Ah.
It's one of those like...
Ooh, ah!
Really.
Why?
Oh, it's this one where you're like...
Bam!
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm gonna save up for...
Maybe... is Payline good?
Why?
But it's the best combo.
I think I'm too, like...
Why spammy for it, but...
I'm just so... I've said this all the other Devil May Cry games.
I'm so not...
Fighting game built.
Brained.
So...
To me...
Learning combos is like...
Oof.
Payline is really good.
Okay.
Try it.
Yeah, you know what?
Let's try it.
Why?
Oh!
Wait.
I don't think I did that.
Why?
Why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why?
Like that?
Why, VTuber, why?
Why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why,
why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, Why?
Why?
Just slam on him.
Pause after the first, and then just mash.
Okay, okay, okay.
What?
No, hold on.
I think I'm mash.
Wait.
Pause.
There we go.
God, this feels... this feels like...
Yeah!
That's what I was gonna say!
Nero!
You!
Wow.
Wowee!
I can't believe... I...
Oh my god, you have become one with Nero!
What sucks is I wish I could like... Oh!
I still got him in the end.
Can't move forward though.
Bruh.
No.
How much of a pause is that?
Is it?
There we go.
Okay, it's a pretty decent pause.
Where's your rev?
I'm practicing!
No.
Pretty long pause.
There we go.
Ah!
Wow!
Wait a second!
Wait, hold on.
Stay down.
Too bad it's not xxxx.
No!
No xxxx.
Holy!
I'm just going...
Boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep boop beep bo Are you guys convinced to be... Wait,
can I even purchase this?
I can!
Learn.
And then we'll learn... Payline.
Payline next.
Then I got my gun up a little bit more.
Wow, only 20%?
Wow.
Oh, wait.
I think I want to.
I think I want to breaker plus two.
Some are locked for story reasons.
Ah, that makes sense.
Roulette spin.
It's good for air combo.
What's a roulette?
I love that they let you try these now.
Roulette spin.
Oh, this one?
Mid-air.
Why?
Wait.
Oh, hold on.
Like that?
Is that it?
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
It is a... Okay.
Ah...
Ah... Pretty easy, yeah.
Air combos for dummies.
It's me!
I'm the dummy!
Mento, thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
Hold on.
I'm trying again.
Eh.
Whoops.
Wait.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I need to practice on you.
My bad.
Sorry.
Hold on.
Ah... Yeah.
Oh.
We can lock in too.
Ah... I see.
Ah... Ah... Pogson, welcome to Bamboo Shipt quar.
You can lock in too.
Wait.
Wait, hold on.
Oh!
Yeah.
Oh, come here.
I got them.
Come here.
Wow.
Now we're at the same time!
Asking for a law.
Oh, let's see.
I messed up.
Oh, sorry.
I'm so used to, like, doing the... with this one.
Wait.
Sorry.
That one.
Press it down.
Hold my devil trigger.
Okay.
I want to keep playing.
I might hold off on this one for now just so I can get another devil breaker.
Spot.
It's one or the other, so... Hmm.
Whoa.
We could get eight.
Eight slots.
Yo.
I'm all revved up.
What does it say?
All that is necessary for evil to succeed is that you do not stand up and fight.
Oh.
And then I heart Osaka.
Is she supposed to be... Osaken?
Because I can see it.
I don't break for... Warlocks.
Capcom is in Osaka.
Oh!
I see.
Oh.
Proud to be... Something.
It's all torn out.
Osaken?
Oh, wait.
What's these ones up here?
If you can read this... My... Rifle... Will kill you before... You hear... It's sound... So edgy.
It's so edgy.
Okay.
All right.
Shall we go?
We're still on... Only... Mission 3.
Whoa.
This looks like a boss room.
Wait.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I think this... This looks like a boss room for sure.
Uh-oh.
Duck.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Artemis.
Whoa.
It's hot.
Uh-oh.
It's fast.
Please don't be... Oh.
Oh gosh.
I can't do all that.
Uh-oh.
What?
No chit-chat or monologue?
Just getting right to the point, huh?
Huh?
Waaaaaah!
I love it.
Whoop!
Spy charge.
Okay.
Hold on.
Whoop!
What are these things anyway?
Bullet hell.
I'm reloading.
Whoop!
Whoop.
Hey!
Don't you...
Whoop!
Whoa!
Are these like portals?
Oops.
Ouch.
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to get closer.
Oh, I can!
Oh my god.
Wait.
Woo!
Come here.
Wait, come here.
Come here, please.
My streak is not... Why, why?
Ow!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can I attach?
Can I... Oh, what's happening?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Where's she going?
What's happening?
Where is she?
This doesn't seem very good.
Oh!
Attack her?
How am I supposed to get up there?
She's dead?
I can't get up there!
Shoot her?
Oh, I didn't... I just noticed the... Oh, okay.
Ah!
Oh, no.
Oh, lady.
Ah!
Whoa!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay...
I noticed... I just noticed the health around it.
Ahahaha!
Ah!
Oh!
No, no, no!
Oh, that was so close.
I don't think I'm gonna... First try this one!
Ahahaha!
Please!
Yeah!
Can I do this one?
Oh!
No, no!
I'm trying!
Here we go!
Oh, my gosh.
My health.
Please.
This thing.
No!
Oh... Please, I'm trying to lock onto you.
Oh, wait.
This is locked on.
Oh, nice!
Ah!
Oh!
Nice.
Oh...
L-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l!
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, gosh.
We're so close!
Nice!
I did it, first try.
Imbi!
Right in the sucker.
Hello?
Do I need to censor this?
Ma'am?
It is Lady!
I was like, is that Lady?
Damn.
Nero, you...
Get your hands off of her!
Don't do anything I would do.
Chica-bow-wow, chica-bow-wow.
Bow-chica-bow-wow, chica-chica-bow-wow.
Kitty-A would kill me right now.
Yeah, she would.
Yeah.
Maybe you have the Lady friend take care of her, you know?
Maybe you have...
Maybe you have Niko bring her to the car or something instead.
You were in a library the last time you fought, lady.
Oh my gosh, you're right!
Nero and V split up to find separate paths.
Oh, dang it.
What color was Nero's arm?
Blue?
But for now...
We have more pressing engagement.
Stuck on this boss like four times when I played it.
Hee hee.
Oh!
V!
Command three demons on the battlefield controlling the flow of combat from a distance.
Oh!
Hell yeah!
Vitality and orbs held carry over, but you can obtain skills for V.
What?
Nero and V split...
I can't read fast enough.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
I'm already changing characters?
Why does his cat look like a giant rat instead?
Like the face just looks a little bit off from being like a panther.
What do we got?
I can buy more Blorb.
That's always a good thing.
Oh!
Porb.
Excuse me.
Are we able to detrate?
Wait, it won't let me go to skills at all.
I'll buy Blorb.
And I buy Porb.
And I buy more Blorb.
Skills are locked on the first mission.
Got it.
Okay.
Well, here we go.
Exciting.
He's so...
All right, buddy.
Oh, okay.
Nothing over here.
Wait.
How do I...
Oh gosh.
The camera.
I can't do anything.
It won't even let me attack.
It won't let me do anything.
Okay.
I can't...
I can jump.
Oh.
We got a big old butt here.
Oh, geniuses.
Be careful.
Yeah.
No shit, Shirley.
Ain't that right, D?
I mean, you are fragile at the moment.
Wouldn't take much to my...
This is like Timon and Pumbaa.
I'm just saying, running away is okay.
It's always okay to run away.
If you're not at point.
He who desires but act not breeds pestilence.
So it is written.
Okay, Shakespeare.
Just remember this.
You and I like to exist.
So get rid of those demons quick.
Cause killing them in my stick.
He's rhyming.
He's gonna rap that.
This guy is whack.
Emo poetry.
Okay, so what do we do?
Attack with Y.
After summoning Shadow.
Press Y to make him perform a close range attack.
Oh.
And I get to just...
Do nothing?
Press...
Press B close to a dying enemy.
Shadow can't finish off dying enemies.
We have to do...
Oh, I have to do that.
Oh, like this guy.
Slice and dice baby.
Come here.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, oh.
After summoning Griffin.
Press X to make him perform.
Okay, so he's...
He's our gun.
Interesting.
Go.
Beep beep beep beep beep beep boop boop boop boop.
And I press...
Press RB...
To dodge?
Okay.
Interesting.
V has the best taunts?
Oh, yeah.
What is that graffiti?
You make me laugh.
Oh my god.
Would you prefer panther to grab things?
I don't know what.
So, so I can just have him.
Oh, neat.
Oh, it's weird.
I don't know how to feel about it.
Okay.
It's weird not being able to control it like myself, in a way.
I am so alone.
The apocalypse has come.
And so have I.
What does that say?
Lady was here.
He's so emo.
You guys don't laugh like that?
If I press B up by it, can I then... Like, this one?
Ah, okay, okay, okay.
That's not so bad, though.
Controlling our little cat.
Oh.
The bird can't aim.
Oh, wait!
Oh my gosh!
We're... We're watching!
The other side!
Hi, Nieru!
Hi!
That's me!
Minto Gaming!
Wait a second.
Nieru, where are you?
Wait, wait, wait.
Where is he?
Still... Oh, there he is!
What if it was actually showing, like, playing my...
Like, my data, you know?
Wait, is it?
Wait.
Hi!
Wait, is it?
It is!
Is that why I look so st...
This is what I look like!
Wait!
This is too funny!
Are you gonna see me dance?
Wait, I can taunt him?
Starring Mid Phantom!
That's me!
Wait, I'm in the game!
This is so funny!
I'm in the game!
Come here.
Kitty, kitty.
Uh...
How do I...
Hello?
Is there, like, anything...
Like, how do I make the cat jump?
Oh!
He can do that!
Okay, okay.
Wait.
Move...
Move your riot to a locked-on target in an instant.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Run!
Thank you so much for the 20th!
And thank you!
Wow!
This is so strange!
I don't think I hate it so far, but it's definitely gonna take some getting used to.
Where am I?
Nero!
Watashi!
Hahaha!
Oh!
I need you!
Slice it!
Nice!
Good job!
Oh!
Wait!
I think this one's timed, no?
Okay.
Big roar, but yeah.
This one's timed.
It's your turn.
At your pleasure.
Gouge it!
Ah!
Oh!
Spam both.
Oh, I guess you can do that, huh?
I was...
I was really mashing it.
I was like this.
I was like this, you guys.
My playthrough, I felt that V was pretty easy to get S-style ranking and above.
Oh!
I see.
Oh well.
I was mashing, smashing there, guys.
What's gonna ambush me here?
Oh!
Wait, I see them.
They're napping!
Can you still see me?
I wish I could've watched the whole thing.
Uh...
Go get them!
Oh.
Look, they're having a little meeting.
Woohoo!
Me!
Oh my god!
Wait.
Go, go, go get him.
Yeah, go get him.
Go get him, tiger.
Landing blow on enemies or taking damage will fill the devil trigger.
Press LB when DT gauge is at level 3.
Summon Nightmare!
Wait.
This guy is not close.
Wow!
Look at him doing!
It's just chilling.
jeszcze chillin' there.
Yeah!
What does he do?
Smash, smash, smash, smash, smash!
Smash... Put the best cash... oh, nope, not yet.
Smash, Smash, Smash, Smash, Smash, Smash,
Wow, it really is easier to get.
Big rank.
Easy.
I was just using two fingers at once.
Oh, thank you.
I was just smash-mashing.
Smash-mashing.
The smash-slinging.
The blast-slinging.
Oh, wait.
I think I see something.
A garb.
Does Nightmare remind me of something?
The big boy?
Maybe, but I can't put my finger on it.
What is he?
Unless that's a spoiler.
Then don't spoil.
Maybe I'll figure it out.
In the future.
Shit for gore.
I did.
One of the fun things about music and taunt him.
Wait.
Or... Oh.
Smelly.
You stink.
I have to keep going.
Oh.
That doesn't seem like a taunt.
That seems like a... Are you okay, buddy?
I would feel... I would feel bad for him.
It's pro-kay.
Where are you, Vito?
Vito?
Are you... Oh.
Stalemate.
Your demon pets will stop moving if they take too much damage.
Keep an eye on their gauges in the upper left corner of the screen.
See how much vitality they have left.
Vito's demons recover from stalemate by themselves over time.
You can speed up their recovery by moving Vito close to them.
What?
Nightmare can interact with the environment, too.
In this level, there are a few secrets by summoning him in other fights.
Cool.
Nightmare can break walls.
Oh!
Thank you, guys.
Vito's gameplay is great because he can taunt and enjoy his theme while just smashing some buttons.
It makes my brain happy.
Yeah!
It's very, like, hands-off.
Well, I'm guessing, like, I'm just... I'm letting all the other animals do the work.
It's pretty nice.
I'm not gonna lie.
Basically, they can die.
But how do... Wait.
Oh!
No!
That's not who I meant to...
Sorry.
How do I see their... Oh, is...
Here, you go... You come back, buddy.
My bad.
When they said upper left, that's... My brain was, like, left button.
Just to give you an idea of what...
This... That's how my brain works sometimes, you guys.
I'm sorry.
Wait, what's that?
What?
Oof!
Ma,
what big ears you have.
Grandma, what big eyes you have.
Grandma, what big noise you have.
Why... Why is it a cube?
He's not an orb at all.
That's so funny.
Okay.
Get his ass!
Good job, team.
Uh-oh.
Run, Vee, run!
Good thing we've got a bird to help us.
And a gorb right behind us.
Wow, this game is really generous with the gorbs.
And like I said, I got one earlier for just opening up the game.
There's login bonuses.
Where am I?
I'm lost.
Probably stuck over there.
Trying to figure out how to get the big tree.
They do hand them out like candy.
What's this?
I will not allow him to gain any more power.
Oh, I gotta put the little... the little stinker in there.
I gotta do that.
Nice.
The little... yeah, the little bug guy.
What are you?
Oh, it's a poor fragment.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I learned something the other day.
Now I can't remember what it's called.
It starts with a T.
So basically...
This is kind of disturbing.
This is a little... this is a little freaky, okay?
This is like... this is... this is some freaky stuff, okay?
Like actually freaky.
Transformers, I wish.
So...
Oh my gosh!
Skewer, you got it!
Yes, it's the teratoma!
So I learned about that the other day.
So...
Sometimes...
Ladies...
Can have a teratoma form...
On their ovaries.
And basically...
What it is, it's like...
It's like a benign...
Usually it's benign, but it's a tumor.
And...
It's not just any kind of tumor.
What it is, is it's a tumor that...
It grows hair...
And it has teeth...
And sometimes it has...
Eyeballs!
And...
It kind of looks like this.
It
kind of looks like this borb!
I'm sorry, eyeballs?
Yeah!
Isn't that freaky?
I don't...
I didn't look into how...
They form...
But like...
What if it's like...
You were supposed to have like a...
What if it's...
What if it's like if you were supposed to have a twin and you ate it?
And then...
It was always in you.
And then it grew into...
A teratoma!
I do not believe that it can have eyes.
I'm telling the truth!
I'm telling the gosh darn truth!
It's so freaky!
Shiri me real!
No!
Oh my gosh, do you guys know Shiri me?
Basically, it's a Japanese yokai.
And it's literally in the name.
Shiri...
Oshiri is butt.
And then me is eye.
It's a yokai.
And it's a yokai that has a butt...
And where the butthole is...
Is it's eyeball!
Why?
There are many evil twin horror movies.
Oh really?
Basically, a teratoma is a tumor with types of cells that shouldn't be there.
Every type of cell starts out as the same thing as how it happened.
That's crazy!
Trying to eat my steak.
Don't worry!
That's the plot of Malignant.
Malignant.
Oh really?
I can't...
I believe that there would be horror movies based around it.
Because in of itself, it's a horror movie, no?
You know that saying?
Truth is sometimes stranger than fiction.
I just googled it.
Well now you learned something today.
So if anybody is ever just like...
Oh no, I have a teratoma.
You'd be like...
Ew!
Oh you...
Freak of nature!
You...
Are...
So disgusting!
You could say...
You could...
Then they'll be like...
How do you know what that is?
That's rude, Minto.
You're right.
I'm telling you not to say that.
I was enjoying my food!
Well...
I'm sorry.
I learned that literally like yesterday.
And then that...
That little guy...
The little porb...
Reminded me of it.
You can blame the porb, okay?
What's this?
Oh!
A...
Warb...
Tree.
Wait!
How do I get that?
Get that!
Now get to work!
Oh!
No!
Wait!
Huh?
Oh!
That's just the residue.
Okay.
Aha!
Nice!
Alright.
Nope.
Get me out of here.
Mmm...
I need...
Crash.
Can I go through here?
No?
The bug!
I'm looking for it!
During my med studies, I learned about teratomas due to them being made up...
Made up of stem cells, which could be studied...
Learned about cellular regeneration.
Yeah!
It's very fascinating...
That it can even happen at all.
The body...
The human body is...
Kinda crazy.
What?
You saw the bug?
I did?
Wait, what do you mean I saw the bug?
Where was it?
Where was the bug?
Or wait, do I grab him from the yellow?
I thought I placed it inside the yellow.
Oh!
Gimme that.
This one's just for fun.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I'm spamming both at once?
Wait, what's that?
Oh.
What is this thing?
I lost Griffith!
Oh!
I see!
Oh wow!
They have...
Low...
Health then.
Okay.
Oh, I see their health now.
There we go.
Oh, oh.
Not yet.
Not close enough.
There we go.
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Still getting used to it.
So far I'm just like...
I'm just spamming.
X and Y.
I'm like barely even looking.
Alrighty.
We got it.
We got our little bug.
Our little buggy boy.
If your bones are damp.
I don't think about that actually.
I mean, I don't have bones.
Of ectoplasm.
Kingdom.
This is my...
Oop.
Kingdom.
This is my kingdom.
The people.
Ectoplasm.
Oh.
Ah.
Use one stock of DT gauge to make Shadow and Griffin attack foes with increased strength for a set time.
Execute the same command again.
Will extend attack time with the cost of more DT gauge.
Interesting.
So far nice.
Whoa.
Wait.
Did I do it right?
Gimme that.
Fill the Ect gauge during battle.
RT.
I'm not reading.
Oh my god.
Oh no my guys.
I'm reading.
Ouch.
I'm not reading.
You can read and walk?
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's right.
I have to...
Whoa.
Oh my god.
Smoke and sexy style.
If any of your animals allows their health, go into stalemate and you have devil trigger activate.
Devil trigger will instantly revive them.
Okay, okay.
Wow wee.
Oh, my earnings.
Grab my money.
Can I go in here?
Oh, I can.
Haha.
Human blood is the source of his strength.
I must cut off his supply.
Okay.
I mean, there's only so many humans now.
My cat is back home after having me in the pet hospital.
Streams were a bit comfort during those nerve-wracking days.
I'm glad your cat's okay.
Yay!
So, can I read this anytime?
Oh my god.
The angel that presided on my birth said little creature formed of joy and mirth.
Go love without the help of anything on earth.
I was surprised.
To see a world in a grain of sand and a heaven in a wild flower.
Hold infinity in the palm of your hand and eternity in an hour.
So...
Please stop reading.
Stop it.
Stop reading.
What's up here?
Oh!
Blar!
If V had an audio book, it's really terrible.
I would listen to it.
I would listen to V's audio book.
Wait, what's this?
Oh.
I guess I could have gotten that myself, huh?
Oh, it's a...
A...
Warb tree.
You gotta be careful!
You gotta...
Oh!
You gotta be careful!
He's fine, everybody.
He's fine.
How is it abuse?
He's doing it himself.
Okay, hold on.
So there's two ways we can go...
Oh, I think...
That probably leads to...
Uh...
What's it called?
This probably leads to...
Around...
Like in an alleyway, I imagine.
Uh...
Oh, it doesn't!
It's completely...
Different...
Area.
Aha!
Okay.
We get another little guy.
Interesting.
Okay.
We get another little guy.
We have a...
Two Nidhogg hatchlings.
Oh!
Okay.
Nevermind.
Thank you.
Uh...
Eraticate them all.
Rise.
Beautiful.
Oh, my gosh...
Holy cow.
Is that it?
Oh.
Come on, get that guy!
Get that guy!
There he is.
Pin him to the wall.
Wow!
Taunt?
Oh, sorry guys.
I forget.
Sorry, sorry.
Oh, wait.
Did I get everything?
Let's go to the other side real quick.
Taunt or read.
Yeah, just so that we can get our DT back.
Set out my birth said little creature formed of joy and mirth go love without the help of anything on Earth.
These rhymes are kinda.
Kinda.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Yup, yup, yup, yup.
Yup, yup, yup.
Yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup, yup.
Oh!
Can I?
But I can't read and attack, know?
Like...
It doesn't seem like I can do that.
Wait, is there any walls for me to break?
Wait, can I break this?
Where did he come from?
Oh, there he is.
I actually can't move.
Oh, my cat!
There's so much to keep track of.
That's why it's...
Because they don't just fight on their own.
You know?
Almost.
These milky barb audiobooks.
I don't want that.
Oh, wait.
I got these guys.
I gotta kill them.
Come on!
Yeah!
And you!
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
I
got it.
Is that it?
Yeah!
What the hell?
Get it out of that.
That was like so cinematic.
No, get that one up there.
Little bird.
There you go.
That looks like a trap right there, no?
Because there's so many...
Okay.
Wow, there's so much to explore around here.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Cinema.
As he does an orchestra.
Woo!
I want that.
So what's my...
Let's see.
Oh, my DT.
You're itching to play.
I can tell.
Is that like nothing?
Oh my god!
Aw, he wants out!
He wants to play.
He wants to hang out.
He's so cute.
Okay, not that way.
This looks like I could break it because of like the...
Wait a second.
What's the gold?
What's the gold on the ground floor?
You see that?
Is that because of...
This guy?
Secret mission?
Oh, that's right!
Oh, uh...
I don't remember what it was, but like where you have to stand for it.
Ah...
I don't remember what you have to do.
You like have to...
Oh, there's more too.
Gotta look down at it.
Isn't there like a place that you gotta...
Stand though?
To then it like activates it and then you can move it to...
I don't remember.
Oh wait, there's even more of it there.
Wait...
What are you doing?
Not here.
Yeah, I think I can only do it from up above.
Okay, anyway.
Break this door!
Slice him.
Nevermind.
We're too weak.
I'm getting overwhelmed by where all to go to.
I guess let's go back...
To...
The other area.
Gotta backtrack.
Oh...
That was here.
Hold on.
Let's go into here...
Uh, first.
Cause...
Or...
Did I explore everything in here?
I'm just making sure.
If I explored everything.
Cause I don't...
Oh, see?
I didn't go over this way.
Or is this just a loop?
Oh wait, maybe it's a loop.
OOI!
I mostly got them.
Press the left stick.
You're right!
It shows me where to go!
Does that say nerd?
Uh...
Nero.
Okay.
Go back.
Don't worry.
I'm exploring.
I'm exploring a little bit.
Before I do...
Stuff.
Now, get to work.
Enjoy the taste of this smell.
WHAAAA!
Oh, ouch.
Oh, no, not again.
I've been exploring.
Oh...
And...
More guy!
Slice him.
And I see you!
Oh, no, no, no, please.
Please!
Woo!
I'm trying to get this guy!
No!
I lost my combo!
That sucks.
I tried.
Oh, hello.
Anything else here?
Maybe no.
So I am supposed to be going this way.
Like, if I...
Is it right click?
Oh, maybe...
Right click or left click?
I am progressing.
It feels like I am.
Wait, so then I should go back the other way.
Oh, nope.
Is left... I missed the blurb?
Where at?
Is it on the other side?
Okay, let's go back.
Okay, this is the progressing way.
And then the other way was not the progressing way.
Okay.
I wish I could make...
Um...
Be a little faster.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Nasty.
Easy.
You will soon?
Yeah, I figured that I will.
Wow, this is very suggestive.
There's a blurb fragment!
Nice.
What else here?
Thank you.
What are you?
Oh.
Oh, I have...
What's this?
Oh gosh.
It's so nasty.
Whoa.
Oh, what?
What?
I'm getting paid!
Make money!
Chop, chop!
Can I go up here?
Uh...
Wait, oh...
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
I found it.
I found the secret mission!
I found it!
Let's see what it is.
I was like, I know there's like a little spot you gotta like sit on- or stand on top of.
Calvin, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Collect all of the warbs!
You think I could do it?
Do I get to keep them?
Oh my god!
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Do I only get to keep...
them if I...
if I win?
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
Oh wait, I'm too slow.
Oh gosh... How am I supposed to get the rest of these?
Oh my gosh... Holy
cow!
You'll need speed upgrade for this.
I think so too.
Wow.
Well that was an attempt.
Did I get to keep them though?
I wish.
Alrighty.
I keep seeing this van.
Wait, let me make sure I got all the... rulers up top.
I keep seeing this van and I think it's Niko!
Open up!
Doesn't look like anything's in there.
Alrighty.
I can't see the name.
Destroy the people...
A phone.
I wonder if I can reach that woman.
Yeah, there we go!
The phone booth.
One moment please.
We're collecting all the money that we can get before we call her?
Destroy the people.
It's nice to get them in stream on the weekend.
Thank you!
Detect- oh.
Dev.
Don't go too close!
Oopsy.
Can you touch me?
Neathog, I never liked this guy.
You.
Test.
I know you.
A box of rocks.
Let's not even mess with this guy V.
He can't even leave the Clyde bot anyway.
He's the Clyde bot parasite.
Yeah, he's a parasite.
Uh oh.
I think he heard me.
Whoop!
Maybe I should've um... called the...
Mox.
I didn't think... I didn't realize...
Oops.
It's fine.
As the air to a bird.
Or the sea to a fish.
So is contempt.
To the contemptible.
Damn, bam, bam.
Alright!
Good luck everybody!
Good luck guys!
Oh my goodness.
It does a big damage though.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh,
oh.
Wow.
He takes big damage.
Er...
Nice.
Wait.
Please, I'm trying to tie it.
Oh, he's doing it!
Come back.
Oh, we're back to these guys, okay.
It's fine.
Bird and cat!
Oh, shoot!
Ouch, ouch.
Nice.
Okay.
Send him to the wall.
Damn.
Oh my gosh!
I need to not get hit!
Come on!
Oh my gosh, I'm not doing any damage.
Cause...
This stinking guy...
Where are you?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay.
And bring him in!
Book if you need to DT drill.
Wait, go to the other one.
Go to the other one.
There we go.
I'm here!
He's back!
Go to the other one.
Oh my gosh!
Back to doing damage!
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Woo-woo-woo!
Bam, bow!
Come on!
My guys are doing so much damage!
I love how my little Gollum guy is just... just... just chillin'.
Oh, I'll chill.
How can I... so... my... oh my gosh... no, no!
I'm worried that I'm not gonna... or rather... hold on, I'll explain after.
Because I think I'm confused about a mechanic!
Of the... of the... of the... everything.
Noooo!
I'm so close!
Okay, okay, what I'm confused about is... I can't... read and fight at the same time, can I?
Because... I was trying to before, but it wasn't working.
You can?
Ah... that's why I wasn't reading, because I was like, how am I supposed to fight if I read?
You just can't jump.
Oh... okay, okay, okay.
You can, but it's just difficult.
Okay, okay, no jumping.
Ah... okay, let's give up.
I'm not gonna waste my rewards.
I was too late.
Dang, I was so close!
Okay.
Yeah, now I can use the phone, though.
The phone?
I wonder if I can reach that woman.
Well, let's not get too close, though.
Don't get too close.
Where is it?
Here it is.
Don't get too close.
Nice.
Alright.
Give me the phone.
Oh!
I'll take that, too.
All according to plan.
Yeah, we got a little taste of how that guy was.
Dang, I really almost one-shot him, though.
And without any skills.
What if I want my panties off?
Is she gonna bust through the wall?
My god!
Ma'am!
That was close.
Good job, team.
Team Malfour.
Good job to you, too.
Good job to you.
Customize?
Customize.
Okay.
This is the most sturdy...
What kind of car is this?
Because it's the most sturdy car ever.
I think there's multiple enemies ready to kill.
Wait.
Oh.
You got to hold...
Circle B to kill them, or else you have to touch the ground again.
Yeah.
Um...
Yes.
You have to...
Kill them.
Wait, hold on.
Did I read your thing right?
If there's multiple enemies to kill, I think you've got to hold the...
Oh!
You have to... Okay.
You hold it.
If there's multiple.
Because, yeah.
I didn't notice that I would like...
Be pressing B after I killed one.
Okay, okay.
Let's see what we got.
Ooh...
Is this just making him go fast?
That's so nice.
Oh, it's an unlockable.
Okay.
How can we unlock it though?
Oh!
Trigger heart is important.
Warbs!
That's nice.
Yeah.
Trigger heart.
But I want to see how much the one is for...
Well, Nightmare is active.
Press...
It'll bleed.
B or A.
Near Nightmare to mount him!
Whoa!
Right atop the demonic beast.
That's fun.
Royal fork!
Get forked.
Rain down demonic canes from on high.
Okay.
Well, I can't even afford that.
But...
Oh!
Hold X longer than release.
Can't afford it.
Oh, gosh.
There's so many things.
So let's...
First of all...
I don't know why you would try trigger her.
I guess to see how much longer...
Okay.
Let's learn that.
Because that's like...
Pretty standard.
Um...
That's like important, I'd say.
Quick play is sprint.
Yeah, but...
It can't be activated in battle.
So should I just hold off?
And get something...
That would be for Griffin and Shadow?
Shadow?
Yeah, I think like after this...
I think after this mission I can get it.
But...
Pick it up with the mission clear orbs.
Yeah, I think that's what I'll do.
Cause I think it would be better to get stuff for...
For Shadow and...
For Griffin...
Or Nightmare...
Then...
Um...
Whoa!
Someone said...
To get the hedgehog.
Uh...
Because we're going into battle...
I won't need it.
Until after.
So...
Plus it's cheap.
Oh my god!
It's just...
Oh...
Hedgehog is pretty easy.
What if we learn these two?
Yeah, Stinger!
What if I learn those two...
And then we learn something for Griffin as well?
Yoni!
Thank you so much for the 5-grip detector!
Learn...
Alright...
Griffin...
What do you know?
Oh, this is X longer...
Double check...
Whoa...
Fire an electric shock that slams the enemies...
Okay...
Yeah, it's a big V...
It's a big V!
Not enough for flank attack...
Yeah...
That's just...
His Stinger...
I think I can only get one thing...
Bird Stinger...
The hold one is good...
Round Robin too...
Go up...
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa...
I was like...
Wait a second...
I thought there was more...
Okay...
So this is...
Hold...
For longer than release...
Okay...
Block into...
Round Robin can shred this boss...
I'm gonna have to now focus on two different sets of combos...
Wait, can I get both?
I can get...
I can get both...
There we go...
V is a nightmare for non-multitaskers...
It will take me some time to understand him...
But...
I think we'll get it eventually...
Alright...
For my double checker...
Okie dokie...
Cool...
Um...
I think that...
Alright, let's go try again...
If you're done...
Get moving...
I'm gonna have a smoke...
And then head out...
Okie...
What does that say?
Bails the butcher?
Hakos?
Hakos tacos...
Toot toot fruits...
Switch...
I don't want my fruits to have me do...
100%...
Always 100% organic...
Glorious greens...
Fishy delights...
Locally caught fish...
Fresh seafood is good for you...
Oh...
Slice him...
Okie...
Oh...
Ok...
What did I...
Wait...
Go...
No...
I don't understand...
Why...
Game...
What the...
What...
What is happening?
The chair was blocking him...
Not doing as good this time...
Let's get our guy in there...
Whoop...
Yeah, just get...
Oh yeah...
Get him down...
Get him...
He's...
We'll get him while he's down...
Oh...
That kinda sucked...
He's gonna go...
I don't even think I got him...
Huuu...
Why...
Please...
Please!
Please read!
Please read...
Why aren't you bullying out your book?
I'm pressing RT I promise!
What is this?
I'm pressing RT.
I've been pressing... There we go, finally.
This is ass.
What do you mean, sure?
You don't know what I'm fucking doing.
I really have.
Read.
There we go.
Okay.
I think you have to hold it down, maybe.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get hit.
I'm gonna get hit, baby.
Nice.
Okay.
Slice.
Woo!
So fast.
I don't know if I'll get it again though.
Ugh.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
Oh there he is.
Yeah!
The cutworm keeps the brow.
What do you say?
Can I get him?
Get him up there.
Get him down here.
Get him wherever.
Woo!
Skewered baby.
Yakitori.
Oh, seven needs...
Okay.
Um, alright.
That's not good at all.
That's not good.
Wait.
Where?
Where are you going?
Are you running away?
That's not a good sign.
I'm afraid then.
That's a little bit more than I can take on right now.
Um...
Oh!
Yeah, I think the time to run is...
Oh my god!
He was crazy.
He was so cool looking.
Yay!
More roll arms!
Nice.
Bro said nope.
I know!
Whoa!
V has some common sense.
And sandals.
Wow.
June 15th.
7.30 AM!
Gosh, it's way too early for this.
V has come and V has left.
Let's go find a game of cards.
These Glyphod roots.
They're everywhere.
Well, we are underground.
Then I guess we have some clearing up to do.
And me without my gardening shears.
Huh.
Nice.
Oh, lady!
Lady, lady.
Okay.
Munch, munch.
I'm eating some snack.
Starting to get hungry.
Oh, but what's new?
Okay.
What was...
Oh, hedgehog was the other thing that I got.
I was like, wait a second.
I got something else and I don't remember.
But it's literally the same thing as a...
As a blockade.
But for the cat.
Okay.
Um...
And then I was...
I was doing the breakthrough.
I was doing that.
Okay.
So let's...
Let's get this.
Nice.
Um...
I guess we could save for something else.
Time to surf, baby.
What was it?
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Flank attack.
Let's learn that.
Imagine having to work next day and waking up at 7am by a big ad demon crab destroying the city.
Should he be mad or glad?
I mean, you should interview the people of Townsville.
It's literally what they deal with, like, daily basis.
And you know what's even more messed up?
Is the Powerpuff Girls live in the suburbs of Townsville.
They don't even try to live close so they can be on the scene immediately.
No, they're just like, we're gonna take our...
We're gonna live on the outskirts because we're smart.
And we don't live in the city where all the monsters are attacking.
Okie dokie.
That should be good.
Mission 5.
The Devil Sword Sparta.
The professor wasn't gonna sell the home.
He was still paying the mortgage.
Now to find an exit.
Yeah.
Alright, nothing over here.
Whoa.
Whoop.
Yeah, get that guy.
Can't see anything.
Wait, I'm holding.
Oh, I'm holding the wrong thing.
There we go.
This is the pleasure.
Wait, I'm trying to hold why, but it's...
Why isn't he doing it?
He's not doing this though.
Whoop.
Twice.
I was holding why to try and have him do the...
The...
But I didn't get it.
Long charge.
Rise.
Slice him.
Ah.
Oh.
It's a long charge time.
Yeah.
Okay.
I understand now.
I understand.
Can't move forward without breaking through these.
Here, you do it.
You guys do it.
There we go.
It's ready when you hear the whoosh.
Yeah, he glows.
I thought I was holding it for long enough.
Can we break this?
No.
One moment, please.
It's like popping a pimple.
Ew.
Whoa.
Where are we?
Okay.
Surfing on shadow actually does damage.
It does?
Who's attacking?
Whoa, sick.
Oh my god.
Gouge him.
Get your book out.
Oh, I did it.
Okay.
Put it, put it away.
I wanna get my roars.
They're gonna disappear.
Please.
Why did you do that?
Why did you knock me off?
I didn't even have my hand on the controller and he shoved me off the thing.
Okay.
I said he knocked me off.
What are we getting?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Woo!
Yeah.
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
Nice.
Is that everybody?
Oh, nope.
Yeah.
Just take care of them.
Woo!
Oh, oh.
That's not, that's not.
You're not ready.
You are.
Okay.
You're ready.
Holy canali.
Nothing up there, okay.
Make sure they're ripe.
Yeah, ripe for the smashing.
You handle this.
No, no, no, no.
Look, look at it.
Yeah, you handle it.
Cause I go in and I smash.
I'm holding Y.
Oh, there it is.
Whoa.
I thought he was ready.
There he is.
Oh, I thought that was a secret mission for a second.
Um, what's over here?
What's over here?
Oh!
Stop, stop, stop, panther.
Stop, stop, stop.
We must get the lore.
Remember to, ah, nice.
Remember to read the book.
I do.
I just have to, you have to like hold it down for it to come out.
And I'm always running around too much.
If I run with...
Yeah, see, it doesn't do it if I'm running and...
Wait, what's over there?
Oh, nothing?
Okay.
Oh, it looks like I can go through there, no?
I think it's just easier to taunt, no?
What's in there?
I can break it?
I can't.
I don't...
I know I can break this.
Come here.
It's your turn.
At your pleasure.
Nah, I can't.
Maybe I go around.
Oh, hello.
Don't do it!
No!
Just get out of here.
Yeah, come on, come on.
No, it's gonna get my warp tree!
No!
Woo!
Wait, did we get it?
Oh, man.
What a waste.
Roar thief!
Ah!
I can't believe!
I wish I could grab-y-grab.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna bring you back, buddy.
Let's just bring you back.
Hold on.
So high maintenance.
How do I get behind there?
Maybe...
It's like...
Oh!
Look at that!
This appeared.
Did I miss this?
Or did it appear out of nowhere?
Um...
Wait.
I came from up above.
Crawl through the gap like a normal person.
I know!
Come on!
V, just get on your hands and knees.
Read in- Oh, you have to summon Nightmare!
Also, reading doesn't work, you guys, unless it's in battle.
Well, does taunt work unless it's in battle?
Let's see.
It's a real...
Roarberry.
Running out of time.
Um...
No.
Doesn't seem to.
That's lame.
No!
Nightmare!
Huh.
A wheel.
Put my...
Put my poor frag.
And then what else...
Whatever else is down there.
Sorry.
The camera is so...
Icky.
Holy cow.
I thought the...
I thought I would be okay with the camera in this game, but...
Uh...
Doesn't seem like it.
Hey, those are my roar butts!
And...
Pusa Queen!
Whoa!
There he comes!
Go get him.
Go get him, tiger.
Panther.
Where is he going?
Queen, where are you going?
My queen!
Where are you going?
I wish I could...
Like, I don't...
Do I have to like, be really close to them?
Because I feel like my...
Guys just like, run away.
You know what I mean?
What is she doing in the corner?
I can't finish her.
Unless...
Oh, now I can.
She was dead.
I was trying to get her.
Recommend locking on.
Okay, so I'll just lock on more, I suppose.
Would be easier...
Then...
Now, can we get up there?
What's all this...
Am I supposed to be running or...
Why is the musical scary?
Come on!
Get it!
There we go.
Thank you.
Should I be running?
Oh.
There's another...
SIG to blow him up.
Very carefully now.
There must be an escape route.
Wait, I can fly this whole time?
Oh my god, I thought it was just a double jump.
This whole time, I could fly!
I feel so stupid.
Only for a little bit.
Yeah, but like that was...
You guys are so stupid.
Get this thing right here!
It's more like a glide.
But that's still huge.
Good job, team.
Anything up here?
Nope.
Okie dokie.
Hey, what's in that hole?
Did we take a look?
Wait, there's robs there though.
See if I...
Let's see.
Yeah, see?
Like that.
Oh my gosh.
How long does it last?
Oh.
Wow, that's pretty good.
Good.
She shoots!
She scores!
Yeah!
I was scared for a second.
Thought I wouldn't get that.
Three points.
I don't think that was three point range, but I'll take it.
Oh, that hurts me too.
Haha.
See?
I'm like...
They go...
They come so far away.
Stop running towards me.
Let's bring my friend in.
Oh, he's coming in through the wall!
Yeah!
Oh yeah, I forgot I have to kill him.
Nice.
Oh!
Oh, I should've saved my friend for later.
I should've saved my friend for later.
Why are you green?
Oh!
That guy's healing you probably!
Oh my gosh, she's so fast.
No,
no, no.
Haha.
Oh, there we go.
Reading time.
I'm trying.
Oh.
You left a little...
Worse for wear.
Read!
Holy cow.
Oh, ouch.
Get her, get her, get her, get her!
Nice.
And...
My turn?
Nope, not yet.
Now my turn.
Nightmare my goat.
Gosh, he's crazy!
Holy cow!
Oof!
Did you guys hear that dog?
Oh!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Wait, which is...
Oh!
Hello!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you.
There we go.
There's a gorb!
Oh!
I miss it this whole time.
Hahaha.
Yay!
Oh!
There's more!
Go get him.
Tiger!
Panther!
Yeah!
Now I get his butt.
Hahaha.
Oh!
There's more!
Don't know why it went towards him like that.
Hahaha.
Except if I'm gonna do anything.
Come here, come here, come here.
Get that butt!
Get him, get him, get him!
Why aren't you guys doing anything?
Duh.
Fight!
Get his butt!
Get the butt!
Okay, like go closer to him and do that again.
Yeah, yeah.
Do that, like really close.
Then my turn.
I think I prefer... Nero's song to... to V's song.
You know?
It's kind of disappointing.
I prefer Nero's song to V's song.
It's so much more... It hypes me up so much more.
Where do you see a phone?
Where are you... Oh.
Over there.
I'm like, am I blind?
Alright.
I like it, but yeah.
It's not that... Oh.
That was so close.
Not that I dislike it.
I just prefer...
Prefer... Nero's.
Oh, he scared me.
I thought that was a guy coming after me.
What else we got around here?
Nothing.
Let's call her up.
You like V's song more?
That's just a preference thing.
Hey, I could use a hand.
Oh?
You got it.
Wait right there.
He's... He's acting vulnerable right now.
Oh my god.
He's just chilling.
What's taking her so long?
Oh.
He's sensitive.
Um...
What's up?
Okay.
We're just gonna... Yeah.
We're just... Yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, where did she come from?
Where...
Where did she come from?
Wait, can I get on top of this horse too?
For some more?
I don't see anything.
But...
The ground.
Yeah, but there's no hole.
Maybe not.
Where's the hole?
Alright, get in there.
Did you know that if you live within 3.5 kilometers of a graveyard, you legally can't be buried there?
Cause it's illegal to bury people while they're alive.
So, stop.
Oh my god.
Do we wanna ride Nightmare?
Or maybe I just upgrade Nightmare.
Bwee.
Oh wait, but I have to have promotion for this.
Uh...
Illegal move!
What does that mean?
Wait, does this also have to be promotion?
Cause I'm on... I'm on his back.
Does this also have to be during...
Promotion?
It hits below the belt.
Let's try it.
I have to keep going.
Whoa!
Wait, I kinda wanna see him.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's so cute!
Now hold B!
I'm holding B.
Gosh, his...
Booty!
Um...
Okay, I think I do have to...
Wait, I didn't...
I didn't figure...
I didn't learn how to...
How to get on top of him.
So, 100% you need promotion to do this.
But I don't think I can do it in there if I...
Don't have it already.
You know what I mean?
L, B, B.
Or A in the air.
I wanna try it.
At the very least.
Alright, come here, baby!
Alright.
I'm on him!
Here we go!
Okay, so he only fights with B.
Okay.
Smack!
What if I...
Smack him on...
Oh!
Bye!
Hmm...
Not a personal fan of promotion.
I feel...
That it's just...
Easier to...
Let him do his own thing.
You know?
Let him, like...
Just...
Be his little baby self.
Because otherwise, I'm controlling three things at the same time.
Like, holy cow!
Oh yeah, I should buy a poor Pong.
Yeah.
Even though he's a giant, nightmare is still my favorite little guy.
No, no, not yet.
Maybe I...
Wait, what does Shadow have extra?
What's a new thing?
Oh, okay, that.
Oh, I know.
I saw Griffin had that too.
Hmm...
Could just buy more...
Porps...
Spinning charge that transforms Shadow's body.
Whoa!
Oh!
So...
Forward or back plus Y.
Wait, that sounds pretty good, no?
We could get this and then Porps.
Hmm...
Oh my god, his head!
This is a monkey D.
Luffy!
Wait, was this only in mid-air?
Uh...
Oh, and in mid-air.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so...
We have to hope that he's in mid-air.
Oh, that's crazy.
As long as possible.
That's a long time.
Hmm...
But I think I might just do the Porp.
Let's buy that at least one.
Buy one Porp.
And then...
Whoa!
Thank you so much for the bread!
Ice cream...
Minto-chan?
Hi!
What do you like?
This is Minto!
You can...
Um...
Woah!
Meno-meno-meno-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo-mo...
Oh my gosh...
I can't stop watching that one lady in oblivion.
Oh, I'm gonna try oblivion tomorrow, you guys.
I'm gonna try oblivion tomorrow.
It's my first time ever playing it.
Playing any...
Elder Scrolls game.
So I'm nervous.
But I want to try it.
And then... And then... But I can't stop watching the clips of this one lizard lady.
Dorygo, thank you so much for the tech.
I can't stop watching this one lizard lady.
And she goes...
So now... So now I'll like run around my maid cafe.
Like if I'm chasing my cats.
And I'll just go...
I'm obsessed with it.
I hope I get to meet her.
Maybe I get this.
And...
We have that.
Back to forward.
Maybe we get this...
Because it's just... Why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why, why.
It's my Nero move.
I'll try it.
Uh...
Yes.
Okay.
Are we good to go?
Sorry.
Sorry, excuse me.
Excuse me.
Can I go in here?
Is this a wall?
Oh, it is.
Oh!
I like how we can still hear her music.
Malthus!
Of course, war trouble.
Not sure about that one though.
Never seen it before.
Not in the other world anyway!
Shhh!
Search for the devil's sword, Sparta.
You know where it is.
He told me to leave it be.
But I'm afraid it still concerns me.
As long as there is a blood descendant of Sparta...
Huh?
I cannot take any chances.
Do you understand?
Whoa!
Find it...
And destroy it!
Only then...
Will his brain be truly realized.
Eww!
Dang!
Oh!
Guess we gotta take care of this guy first.
Oh my god!
He's so cool!
Elder Gryon Knight!
Whoa!
I see.
I know what you are.
Don't worry.
I'll be gentle.
I know what you are.
I don't know.
Let's bring...
Our friend out.
Keep going.
Woo!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop!
Get me outta here.
Oh,
this creature...
Bring... bring the book out.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho!
So, you thought...
Feels immense.
It's not the type of poetry...
Wait, what am I gonna say?
Where there's a will...
There's a way.
Let's go.
Nice.
What's happening?
Holy cow!
What's going on?
Is that water though?
Oh my god.
Is this that stickin' horse?
A rare species, but apparently not quite extinct.
Ah, dang it.
Dice, slice, and dice him.
Guys!
Send him right back.
Wait, what is that?
What's that thing that's growing?
What is it?
What is the thing that's growing?
Woo!
Oh, but he's back.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh, dang it!
I just noticed that I was doing that combo.
Catch freaking it.
Holy cow.
Get me outta here!
I think I might wanna.
There we go.
Ah!
Ouch.
Oh
my gosh.
Oh no, my cat!
Or my bird!
My bird!
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
What is happening here?
My bird's back!
My bird!
Oh!
Holy cow!
Come on, you guys!
Please!
Slice- Slice- Get!
Get, Get em!
Get em!
There we go, there we go, there we go, there we go, there we go!
And me!
My turn!
My turn?
My turn almost.
Oh my gosh, that the big- The big damage!
Wait, when is it my turn?
What's up, I'm not... Not yet.
Close.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm trapped in here!
Oh my animals are dead.
Oh shoot.
Come on guys!
Wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up!
Wake up!
That's awkward.
I can't do anything right now.
I don't want to be in the slow-mo zone.
Oh gosh.
I'm trying to dodge, but I can't.
Oh my gosh, this is so bad.
This is so bad, you guys!
This is so bad!
My animals!
Come back!
He's back!!!
He is back!!!
Oh my God, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna die!
Holy cow!
Oh my god.
Oh my... I was just trying to build DT.
I'm not fine.
I'm not okay.
Well done, Gamer.
Thank you.
Sucky, thank you.
Thanks for the gift.
The boy.
What of the boy?
Oh, Nero.
Give me that.
What is that?
Now do I get the control time?
Meep, thank you so much for the 515.
Congratulations on avoiding all the spoilers.
Wait, what?
Once we are near the Sparta, even I should be able to sense its presence.
We clutched that, you guys.
That was pretty...
That was pretty spooky scary.
Oh.
No continues bonus.
Hehehehe.
Wow.
Risk taker.
No running.
Yeah, but not by choice.
Oh.
We're switching back already?
Wait, but I just got used to him.
Hahaha.
Oh, no.
I just got used to him.
Wait, do we got a new piece?
Hey.
I got a new arm for ya.
Was it...
Tomboy?
And...
Buster Arm.
No.
I really worked out a sweat on that one.
Okay.
I can't...
I don't have enough space for all these.
Uh...
I guess...
Wait.
How much is it to...
Get a new...
I guess we could get a new spot...
Slot.
Hmm...
Try them out in the void.
Yeah, I will.
But...
I'm just making sure there's nothing else that I wanted to get while...
I guess...
If I really want to save up for Wiresnatch.
Don't worry guys.
We'll try them out.
Let's take out a youth.
We'll just switch these out.
Oh, oh.
Okay.
Oh.
No, no, no.
To the void!
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I was like...
There we go.
Okay.
Wait.
No, wait.
Oh.
I forgot to...
Wait.
Hold on.
I jump.
Jump.
B.
Wait.
How am I supposed to jump B?
Am I charging it long enough?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Charge.
Helter Sculter.
Tomboy.
Wait, what?
Does it do the rev for me?
Does it, like...
Do the rev for me?
It charges my moves?
It charges my moves!
Max rev!
Until when?
For how long?
Try the revolver, wait...
Try your gun.
I can't aim.
You guys, I can't aim.
You guys, I can't...
That's crazy.
And then this is it.
No way.
Oh...
My god.
Just like DMZ4!
It feels so good.
Oh my god, just like DMZ4.
Let's reset.
I should probably just do like a separate build out.
Like, or load out for, uh...
For, um...
Gosh, punchline takes a long time to...
To rev up.
It's kind of crazy.
Let's see.
Helter Skelter.
Okay.
Gosh!
I love Tomboy!
Oh my god!
Wow!
When does it stop?
When I tell it to.
But it just stays?
There's like...
Wait, so I have a question though.
Don't you...
Doesn't it break if you...
Get hit?
So...
If I got hit, then it would break.
Okay.
Okay, so I...
Okay, so that is the...
Okay.
Oh!
Golly!
Okay.
Alright!
Okay, okay.
Alright.
I was gonna say...
It just feels broken otherwise.
Uh...
Hold on.
Wait.
I can't...
Oh!
You can't move!
So I'm trapped?
I'm currently trapped?
I can't walk side to side at all?
That kinda sucks.
You have to jump out of it?
Wait.
What do you mean?
Oh, you can charge the guy.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I wanna try that.
Let's hit it.
I'll turn a scouter!
I'll beat a Brit...
Oh!
That's right!
Cause you can throw it anyway.
I forgot about that.
Thank you.
But I don't wanna remember that.
Actually, I don't wanna remember that.
Because I don't wanna just be breaking arms willy-nilly.
Um...
Okay.
Charge.
Ah!
I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
What was that?
Oh, charge it up, right?
What?
Oh!
Stop charging Tomboy.
Just charge the gun.
What?
How am I supposed to know that?
Sorry.
I meant people just say to charge.
I thought charge the gun and Tomboy.
I thought you meant charge Tomboy.
Okay.
I'm charging.
Is that it?
Hold the gun.
I am.
With Tomboy active.
Thank you.
Oh!
What was it like when I just...
Wowie powie.
Cool.
I think we're good.
Well, actually, hold on.
I mean...
Is there anything special?
Well...
I guess it was just...
Just this, right?
Big dam...
Oh, air too.
Wait, uh...
Wait.
Oh, hold on.
Let me get him up in the air.
There we go.
Ah ha ha.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can snatch.
Oh, true.
Wait.
Brah!
Samadram.
Alright.
Let's keep going.
I'm gonna switch my...
My...
Build a little...
Or magazine.
Let's see.
Wait.
Let's switch with...
Tomboy.
And then after...
We'll have...
Busterron.
What?
What did I get two of those?
Okay.
Okie dokie.
Artichokey.
I think we're good.
Woohoo!
Mission six, baby.
Steel impact.
I asked.
Look at...
Why is he...
Why is he looking at her like that?
Why haven't they given Lady any clothes?
Nico, do you not have a wardrobe?
Nico, do you just wear the same outfit every single day?
All the time?
Why?
Nobody brought spares.
Does nobody have anything to give her to wear?
They're on a budget.
Clearly.
Oh!
Hi, lady.
Looks like she's having a nice dream.
She looks so peaceful.
Hold on.
I'm gonna eat some...
I'm gonna eat a quick snack real quick.
Quick snack real quick.
I got some almonds.
Hopefully they're not poisoned.
But I'm already dead, so...
Buddy, what you munching on?
Almonds, buddy.
Look in the membership!
What are you?
Oh, put clothes on her?
What are you talking about?
I'm a respectful lady.
I respect women.
Of course I would.
Sorry if you can hear me munching.
Now, what kind of outfit would I put on her?
Can you give us a good crunch?
Oh, that wasn't good at all.
Hold on.
Let me get a new one.
Okay.
I have a brand new almond.
If you don't like...
Munching ASMR.
Don't listen.
For like one second.
Here we go.
One almond.
Whoa!
That was a crunch.
Alright.
Mission start.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Got a pretty smokin' body though.
Yeah, she do.
Not that...
I was...
barely even noticed.
You know...
You should go do your thing.
I got this.
Yeah.
Nero hates women loving women.
I know.
She's a girl's girl.
He's too big to leave alone.
We'll take care of it.
Oh wait, what?
Stay alert.
Yeah.
Wait, we're taking care of that?
Not even B would take care of that.
KDA only.
Yeah.
He's so like...
Kill Gomesh!
He's so...
Like...
How do you say?
Oh, I see.
Okay.
Understandable.
S...
Not straight list.
He's so like...
So serious.
I guess.
You know?
He's just such a serious guy.
He doesn't take any sort of jokes.
Um...
Okay.
How do I get up there?
Anything I can jump?
Oh wait, I can get his legs.
Wait, jump, jump, jump.
Oh!
Ah!
I see, I see.
Wait.
Oh.
I got him.
Get up on the Hydra's back!
Wait.
Wait, why am I doing that when I just have...
Tomboy?
Why am I doing that when I got Tomboy?
Woo!
Holy moly.
Oh my god.
Rude!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
I can't see.
Where do you think you're going?
Yeah!
Uh...
I wish I had...
Wait, how do I get over there?
Okay, we're just gonna...
Oh!
Nice.
Not that I need it right now, but...
Uh...
Oh, nice.
Um...
Uh...
Oh my god.
Let me...
Let me grab you.
Whoop!
There goes Tomboy.
Nooo!
Oh my god.
So sad.
My Tomboy!
Come on.
I need you to jump, buddy.
Oh!
Actually, that works.
For us.
Maybe Buster Arm is not great for this fight.
Oh, dang it!
Buster the red spot?
Will it work?
You have to wait for the big stun.
Okay.
What are you doing down there?
Yeah, what are you doing down there?
Ha!
You didn't think you did that all by yourself, did ya?
You know...
I bet you taste like chicken.
Oh, you want great...
What should I...
What do you mean Buster now?
Should I...
Like Hold Buster or...
Or...
Just Small Buster?
Hold Buster?
Well...
Guess it's just you and me, cockroach.
Just use.
Okay.
Hold.
Good job, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
You getting back up now?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, kinda.
But it's gone.
There it was.
Oh, I lost it.
Please!
Oh, there we go.
Please, grab it.
Nope, nope.
Grab that part.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm just...
Okay, it's gone now.
Oh, eh.
No, no, no.
Yeah.
Ow.
Oh, so slippery.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
I got another Buster on.
Yippee.
Wait.
And...
Nope, not yet.
Okay, just kidding.
Thank you.
Ah.
I thought I was down.
No.
There's like little drones.
What are you doing up here?
Go away.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my
God.
That's quite annoying.
There we go.
Well, at least I got that.
That's what I was coming for.
This thing is so cute though.
I kind of really like him.
No.
Not this thing again.
Please.
Oh, please.
No.
No, not you.
Ouch.
Please.
Yes.
There we go.
I tried to dodge it.
It's okay.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
That's okay.
Is he down now?
It's different.
The minimum amount of damage.
What is it?
No.
Please.
Please!
No, no!
Circle!
No, no, no!
No!
There we go.
Really?
Why?
Please!
Oh my god.
This stinking thing.
Oh, at least there's health here.
That's good.
Oh, and some Rorbs.
I'll take that.
Please!
Get close!
The saddest way.
Oh, that's so silly.
Ugh.
Everything is, everything is vegetable.
What?
Yo, ladies away.
Got any questions for her?
Better make it fast.
Hey, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We could use that.
Pick it up.
Oh.
New arm?
This one?
Next to it.
Come on, Nico.
This one?
Sure.
What were you, what do you mean sure?
Which one were you referring to?
Why is there canned food?
Why?
I think that's pretty useful too, though, no?
Yippee!
Guys, I gotta find my eye drops real quick.
I'm too focused.
My ectoplasm's all dried up.
Actually, I think they might be in another room.
Your eye drops are in another castle.
Can I go get them real quick?
8 57 AM.
Let's watch this and then we'll, I'll go grab them.
Nico.
Good morning, lady.
So what happened to them and Trish?
They end up like you?
What?
I didn't think about that.
Trish, she... she was captured.
I remember that.
I'm not gonna have to fight Dante.
I don't know what happened to Dante.
Damn it.
You can't travel through here in a car.
Yeah, we know.
We're just waiting on you.
There's only one way up that tree.
But is it gonna be evil possessed Dante?
I'm glad to see you look so well.
You too, I guess.
I found these.
If they're of any use to you, they're yours.
Wow.
I can make something truly awesome out of these.
Hell yeah.
How old is Lady?
Is she?
Shocker.
Can we trust him?
Your guest is as good as mine.
He might be useful.
I like how nobody knows who the hell V is.
Enough talking.
Get some rest.
You need it.
Forties?
In her forties?
She looks amazing.
Late thirties.
He's just some random...
Everyone's like, can we trust this guy?
I don't know.
Yo!
Lady, wake up!
It's time to get to work.
I was just told to get some rest.
Aw.
You were just told to get some rest?
Well, we need to make a path.
So start digging.
Come on!
She doesn't even have clothes on!
Got something to wear that's good for digging?
Whoa!
What?
I get to pick?
No way.
Okay, hold on.
Let me go.
Let me go grab.
Let me go grab my address real quick.
I know where they are.
Give me a second.
Whoever I stop on.
Nero!
Okay, bear, babe.
Hold on, guys.
I'm also gonna go grab drink.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna go grab a drink.
What was that face?
I was like...
I can't...
I don't even think I can recreate it.
I was like...
Sorry, I've made some tea.
I made myself some tea.
You can get a mod to remove the lens flare.
I'm so cute when she's making AFK faces.
Yeah!
A nice cuppa.
Yeah, a nice cuppa.
I guess I'll keep playing at...
I don't know.
I don't know, actually.
I would feel really...
So...
I don't wanna, like, keep playing.
Okay, hold on.
No, I do wanna keep playing.
I...
Worry...
If I...
Play as, like, V a lot...
And then they're like, Oh, by the way, you have to switch back to Nero.
And I'm like, Oh, shoot.
I don't remember how to play Nero anymore.
You know?
Oh...
Hmm...
I'm gonna play as Nero.
Are the cutscenes different, though?
Depending on who you play as?
Are they different?
Okay.
I got a new arm for ya.
No?
Oh, okay.
Got a new arm...
Ride!
Aw, yeah.
Rad!
Time!
It is time!
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
We have so many now.
It's so expensive!
A devil breaker that controls time projects a special field that slows all objects within its range.
Whoa.
Does that include meat?
I'm sure there was an update that removed the lens flare without a mod.
No way!
Okay.
Rawhide.
Boast the widest attack range.
Use the metal whip for a long distance strike or to reel in certain heavy enemies.
Oh, I see.
Now I just need to make more space.
Wait, but we're so close to...
What was it?
Wire Snatch 3.
But I want to try them both.
Obviously.
So let me...
Uh, edit.
Yeah.
Oh!
I'm so stupid!
No!
Oh!
Go back!
Okay.
Phew!
Um...
Let's try it.
Okay.
How much further is it?
Of a...
Snatch?
Not that far.
That was pretty far though.
Wait.
I didn't see what its normal attack is.
Woah!
Neat.
Oh wait.
Wait.
Oh my god!
He loses frames!
He becomes like 5 frames per second!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha
ha ha ha!
Oh my gosh!
That's so funny!
Not so fast!
Got it!
Woo!
That's fun.
Alright.
So now...
What I want to do is...
Uh...
Enemy settings?
Let's do that.
What?
Okay.
Oh but it's like so small.
Oh my god!
Steins gate!
Oh relax!
That's hard to...
Aim it.
I guess it's easier if I get him...
Bring him close to me.
If I'm like...
Come here!
Oh whoops!
Hmm...
And then does this like make it a really big...
Take your time!
Yeah!
This is what the horse does.
But for how long?
Come on!
Wow!
That's quite a long time, no?
That's pretty long.
Dio liked that.
Nah, too slow!
Too slow!
Wait...
Uh...
Reset.
Cause what I wanna do is...
Is it any different?
Wait, what if I...
Okay, cool.
It's pretty much the same though.
Okie dokie!
Let's switch out our...
I'm gonna save up for...
Wiresnatch 3.
Um...
Let's see what else we can get after that.
I wanna get the breaker plus 3, but I will resist.
I'm gonna use this as a last resort.
Haha!
But I like rawhide.
I feel like I will use that.
Wait.
Go down.
Why don't you go down?
Maybe because I need to select it.
Um...
And this is the one...
This is...
Yeah.
That's the one...
Wait.
Nope.
Uh...
You...
Switch you out.
Okay, there we go.
Maybe I'll try that.
Yeah, this is DMC4.
And then this is the time stop.
Okay.
I'll try this.
Hmm...
No tomboy?
I don't have any tomboy.
I'd have to buy a new one.
That sucks.
Which I guess I could.
Yeah, we broke ours.
Eh...
How much is it?
A thousand.
I'll just...
I'll just try to rev.
I'm sure you'll find one.
I think so too.
I think we'll be good.
So, we've gone through mission...
Three, four, five, six...
We're on mission seven.
Let's go!
Wow!
We're...
We're going crazy.
You two please.
Is you two being a little stinker?
It's definitely not me.
Can I shoot this one from here?
No.
Oh, that one's blocked from...
Wow, that's kind of funny.
Alright.
Uh
oh.
New guys.
We got the lizard people.
Riot.
That's V's path.
Ah...
Well, where is he?
He's not doing a very good job.
Where is he at?
Lizard.
Oh no.
Wait, did I just blast that guy?
How did I blast him so easily?
Wait.
Stop parrying me!
Ah!
Dang it.
Ah, shoot.
Starring the DMC crew.
Let's go.
Come on!
Oh, nice.
Um...
I guess I just lost that arm.
Okay.
Posh.
Is he already out of here?
Dang, he's kind of fast.
You can follow if you want, but I'm going ahead.
Okay.
Yeah, follow if you want.
Damn it.
I feel so much more comfortable as Nero.
But I did like playing as V.
I think V is...
I don't want to say easier.
Easier is not the right word.
Orb.
Got the classic buster arm, baby.
Grab him and smash him.
A classic...
Classic buster arm move.
I still like just being able to beat up anything that I like so easily.
You know what I mean?
Oh.
Where are you?
We got...
Oh!
We got hel...
Hel...
Helter skill through.
If you attack just before she lands a hit to open up, it's been secure.
Wait, who's she?
It's my birthday, Omni!
In lieu of a song, could you tell us a heartfelt compliment for one of the sloppy sisters?
Your pick.
A compliment...
Happy birthday, Omni!
A compliment for one of the sloppy sisters.
Um...
Oh, death scissors.
Uh...
I will say one for each person.
Um...
I love how...
How silly Snuffy is.
And how...
Great of a yes and kind of...
Um...
Uh...
Person she is.
Those are always the most fun to be able to collab with.
And she's just so silly and cute.
And I like that.
Uh...
With Laimu.
I love how...
Level-headed and dependable she is.
And how...
I...
Um...
Really admire that she's just got such a great head on her shoulders.
And she's just such a sweetie pie.
And I really love her.
And...
Doki!
Not gonna give you guys a satisfaction.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ewww...
Dammit.
I miss.
Oh, I forgot that I wasn't using...
Gross!
Yeah!
There we go.
Nice.
Oop.
Yeah!
Jelly donut.
That's the...
Juiciest jelly donut I'll have ever had.
Rise and fall of Spencer.
God, these...
These signs are made of...
Cardboard.
Who's Spencer?
The night just started.
I like these ads they're selling.
What are you wearing?
Hey.
Hi, Orca.
You know, Orca.
I'm pretty sure you're...
Shadow banned for me on Twitter.
Cold drinks!
Clearly she had...
Choice paralysis.
Wait, what?
Hold on.
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I have to keep...
I have to keep pausing to...
To read your...
Super chats.
If they go too fast.
She had...
Choice paralysis for Doki's compliment.
Right?
What did Orca do?
I don't know.
It's what...
It's not me that did it.
It's Twitter.
I don't know.
Maybe the name...
Areola enjoyer...
Just kind of like...
Struck a nerve with him.
Oop.
Dang it.
I think I just lost my arm.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, I always forget to...
Jump up with them.
There we go.
Holy cow.
I always end up...
Accidentally losing my arms.
Ha ha ha ha.
Kinda sucks, actually.
Because...
It's not that I'll be weak without them.
But like, it's...
Kinda just sucks.
I'm gonna have to buy so many of them.
Sheila!
Smoking sensation.
I would like to view the show.
Oh.
Oh, what's going on?
Oh!
We just got that guy.
What did you...
Fear that I must destroy these?
Woo!
Where'd that guy go?
Hello?
Crawly?
Wait, where'd he go?
Did he des- Did he spawn?
What a little wimp!
What a little doofus!
No, he ran away.
Aw, man.
It's okay.
It's fine, I guess.
Yes.
Coward baby.
So true!
That's exactly what I was thinking.
Oh, okay.
There's no going back.
Hope you got what you wanted.
Or wait.
Oh, this is the way back.
Just kidding.
Ow!
We're going down here.
Okay.
Did I get everything in here?
Let me just double check.
Yes.
There's V over there.
Doing something.
I hear something.
I hear someone.
I hear V, I think.
What's he doing?
The DMC crew!
Woo!
Where are you?
Oh, there he is!
I wish I could go help him.
I got my own stuff.
Nailed it!
Oh, this thing again.
Oh, hell no.
I'm not letting this spawn any more of these guys.
Oh, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Woo!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Get me out of here.
Leave me alone!
Oh, we got another helter skelter, baby.
This place is so...
crawling.
If you were able to be in a video game, what would you like best?
And would you terribly mind the above average being dead angst?
Unless that's not the ghost mate's cup of tea.
Wait, what do you mean?
Um...
That's a ghost mate.
That's a ghost.
There's always gonna be angst.
Cause you're dead!
Wait, is V down here?
Still?
Nope.
What game though?
Smash Bros.
Um...
Well, if I'm a ghost in any game, I could probably just take it easy.
Unless it's like Luigi's Mansion.
So definitely not Luigi's Mansion.
Do not wanna be in there.
A warrior?
But it's the human that kisses the ghost.
The girl.
Hmm...
I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel like a...
Like a...
Animal Crossing is such an easy answer, you know?
But it's kind of a cop-out.
Cause it's just like...
Ah, yeah.
Taking it easy, baby.
Where are you?
To...
Oh.
Metal Gear...
Metal Gear?
Oh, TFC2 style.
Oh, ow.
Why did I go into it?
Why am I so stupid?
Sorry, I got Metal Gear on the brain.
Probably because you asked me what world I would wanna live in.
And I can't just say Metal Gear!
Because I don't think I would wanna live in that world!
Oh
my gosh!
Where did you come from?
Please.
Oh,
I can't tell which way I'm facing.
To do the combo.
I'm attacking you instead.
Oh!
Where'd you come from?
Oh, they're back!
They're both back!
What, the other one's back?
Ah!
There's three of them!
There's so many of them!
Oh my
god.
Ah!
There's these guys too!
Oh my god.
Ah!
No, I think I just broke my arm.
That sucks.
Oh!
Noooo!
Please!
Dodge!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna run out of arms for real.
Yeah!
Parry!
Come here.
Oh!
He like, corrects himself.
That's kinda crazy.
Oh!
John!
I hate these guys so much!
I think I might actually prefer the scissor guy.
I think I might prefer the scissor guy over these guys.
Holy cow!
They're tough.
They're...
Oh!
Buster arm.
I was like, I think I see...
Something glowing here.
You still win those.
Somehow...
Oh my gosh.
We're doing what...
I've always dreamed of doing this.
I've always wanted to go...
Oh no.
I see them.
I've always wanted to go...
Up a down escalator.
You know?
Oh, what the hell is this?
Not while I'm getting attacked.
No!
Wait, this is so evil!
Oh my god.
I said the scissor man and he appeared.
Oh, I hate jinxing.
I hate...
I hate my...
Prophetic...
Why am I...
Why...
Why do I always know what's gonna happen?
No!
I hate...
I hate having the gift of prophecy!
Please!
Come here.
Oh gosh.
Oh
my god.
Where did you get your sword back?
Or...
Oh, I only broke half of it.
Please.
This is so confusing.
Ouch.
Oh, there they...
I was like, could I...
They're trying their best.
This is so sad.
Oh, they're really trying.
I'm just gonna put them out of their misery.
Sorry.
That was so funny.
I was like, why isn't the music stopping?
That's cold.
I know.
I could ask you what your favorite weather is, and somehow you'd start thinking about Metal Gear.
Yeah!
Yeah, sorry.
Oh my god.
I need to focus on this first!
Do it!
There we go.
Alright.
Come here.
Oh no!
Is this gonna break it?
Oh, it didn't.
Yeah!
Oh, I miss you so much.
My sweet, sweet arm.
Classic.
Yeah!
Mural.
Buster arm.
Woo!
Anything else around here?
Oh, this...
This one doesn't work, huh?
Oh.
There we go.
Phone?
Wait, did I miss her?
Where at?
Here?
No.
Oh, I see it!
Moshi Moshi!
Nico-chan!
Hi!
Nani ga suki?
Watashi!
Lord, I've got a job for you.
She's...
Madam!
I love the way that she is.
I have slots for two.
Oh, but you know what?
I do have...
I can just...
I don't have to buy some yet.
In fact, I'm just gonna keep one open because we find them...
We find them not...
Not so...
Like...
We find them pretty often is what I'm trying to say.
Alright.
So now we have Wire Snatch 3, baby!
Yeah!
I think this might have to be my last mission though, you guys.
I was gonna play longer, but my eyes are killing me.
I don't know why.
Sometimes my eyes are just...
Maybe I can do another mission.
We'll see.
A hundred hours into blueprints?
Oh my god.
We'll see how I'm feeling once we get through this mission.
I plan on playing longer though.
I wanted to play like...
Like three more hours.
I might though.
We'll...
Actually, no.
We'll see once I...
I can buy a Bor...
Bloor...
We'll see how I am...
Um...
At the end of this.
Or...
It might take me three hours to beat a single boss, you know?
More Bloor.
Where are we going?
Adjustment.
Hate that place.
Next mission's pretty long.
Okay.
Then maybe we will cut it here.
After this mission.
Woah.
Oh my god.
Cinematic.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Okay.
Let's see.
Over here.
Woah.
Gosh.
You scared the heck out of me.
This...
Ouch.
I did not...
There's no...
Wait.
I don't want to touch you just yet.
Oh.
Just kidding.
I do want to touch you.
Okay.
What's the best way to handle this, you guys?
Oh.
I'm trying to rev, but I'm not doing a very good job at it.
No!
I tried.
There was an attempt.
Masapako!
Thank you so much for the break!
Hello, hello, hello.
Hi, hi, hi.
Hope you had a good stream.
I'm just playing some more Devil May Cry.
I ain't crying yet though.
But these guys in chat...
That's another story.
Okay.
I think we gotta slide down here.
Oh!
Spooky.
Oh my gosh!
We're going to the opera!
We are going to the opera!
I know it, right?
Wee, wee, wee!
Uni!
Thank you so much for the podcast!
Thank you!
It's the opera time!
Is this a boss?
I'm gonna guess it is.
The Phantom of the Opera!
In sleepy sang to me...
In dreams he came...
There I go!
Thank you for the vibe!
Thank you!
Oh!
V's back!
No!
Stinkin' way!
What?!
Angelos!
Oh my gosh!
The Angelos are multiplying!
Nice!
Getting the band back together, huh?
My favorite boy band!
What evil lurks?
You okay?
Salamandra!
I must destroy...
Thank you so much for the 20 games!
Thank you!
Angelos!
It's the Angelos gang!
Wait, are we gonna be fighting together?
No!
That's so fun!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, this is insane!
What is happening?!
What is happening?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Oh!
Oh...
Weed!
Come here!
I'm taking it one guy at a time.
I'm just bullying this guy.
I'm really bullying him.
Suplex!
Dang, I really thought that was going to do it for him.
Who has left?
Oh, watch out, buddy!
Watch out, my friend!
A dodge rat?
I can't tell what's happening.
I'm gonna get this guy.
I just snuck up on him.
Oh, wait!
I just noticed!
I have a different...
I have a different... I lost my buster!
Noooo!
I'm bullying this guy, don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm bullying him.
I'm bullying him.
Every Angelo has their day.
I'm not slacking!
I literally got a couple guys here.
I'll get this guy.
Oh, wait.
I'll get him.
I'll kill him.
Don't worry.
He's mine.
There we go.
Okay.
Just one left.
Oh,
nice parry.
Now we jump him, yeah.
Jump his ass!
Oh my god, this guy's getting...
No!
Give me your lunch money!
Give me all your money!
Give me everything you're worth!
Holy cow!
Wait.
Try this.
Stop!
He's already dead!
Dude!
Hahaha!
Took us long enough to get here.
What?
Tired already?
I just remembered something.
This town was attacked.
Once before.
How do you know that?
Set so.
So nano-car.
I can still see it.
What do you see, Kylo Ren?
What do you see?
Legendary jumping boss?
Thanks.
Are you being sarcastic?
How convenient.
Oh!
I knew he was gonna...
I was like, I knew he was gonna react that way.
Wait, does that mean we'll get our arm back?
Oh, please, God.
Please!
I want my arm back!
If we get the sword, I want my arm back!
I'm gonna get my body back!
Sparta is not Yamato.
Yeah, but it's still a sword!
It's still a sword!
Do we get a whole new body?
I don't know.
You don't like robo-arm?
Okay, fair.
Body-yaddy-yaddy, baby!
Guess there's no point thinking about it.
Un Perfect timing.
Now we're starting to act like a team.
Ew.
You guys flirting with me?
Knock it off.
Get in the car.
My man is happily taken.
She's fine.
I love Nico.
She's so silly.
She wants us.
I don't know about that.
Oh, lady's got a shirt on now.
No!
Demon King.
That sounds pretty intense, no?
That sounds pretty... Hmm.
Pretty crazy, no?
Mod the game.
Make her shirtless again.
Trying to decide if I want to do another mission or not.
Mission 8 will be really long.
Maybe I'll call it here.
I'm not trying to rush through the game or anything, so.
I just wanted to play more today because I only played for so little last time.
So I just wanted to make up for it.
But we got through...
You know, we had 3, 4, 5, 6, 7...
That's 5 missions, baby.
We got through 5 whole missions.
Yeah, so...
Good progress.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
Probably...
Two more streams, maybe.
Depending.
How good I am.
We'll see.
Yeah.
Thanks for streaming, Minto.
You need to rest for your healthy.
Thank you!
Yeah.
I...
It's...
I'm in such a rock and a hard place because I'm like, I want to stream long, long.
But...
I try to not stream long, long.
Because I...
Don't want...
I need to rest on my throat, too.
So...
Nah...
You know.
But today I'm feeling good.
Today I am feeling quite good.
Um...
So...
I think...
I think, uh...
Uh...
In terms of the medicine, I'm...
I'm feeling much better from it, so...
Mm-hmm.
Thank you guys for your patience.
With me...
Uh...
Getting through it.
So, yeah.
I appreciate it.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you for the fun stream!
Thank you!
Your willingness to hold Doki's hand through the meandering hella visage speaks louder than any compliment.
Which we'll be finishing this week as well.
And...
Uh...
Before...
Before we end off today, I have a cover...
Coming out...
On...
Tuesday.
April 29th.
Or April 30th.
Depending on your...
Time zone.
I wanted it to be...
A...
Uh...
So, basically, it's a song from Metal Gear, which is...
You know, everybody covers...
And everybody sings in karaoke.
They all sing Snake Eater.
But I...
This is actually probably my favorite...
Metal Gear song in the whole...
Series.
I'm not gonna lie.
I love this song.
And so...
I wanted it...
In the games...
The games take place on April 29th and 30th.
So I wanted it to kind of...
Depending on your time zone.
It's either April 29th or 30th.
So...
It's relevant in both...
Times.
I'm a genius.
But I really like this song.
So...
Um...
Yeah.
You don't have to like Metal Gear to like this song either.
It's...
It's just a...
Nice little...
Jazzy song.
Mint, you're a genius.
Thank you.
Don't skip the sacks this time.
Oh, there's no skipping.
Nope.
No skipping.
So...
Um...
That's my...
That's my advertisement.
For today.
Yeah.
Thank you guys for helping me again.
Especially figuring out the moves and stuff.
Sorry if I learn something in the void and then I completely forget to use it.
But...
But, you know...
I'm a panic mode in...
In battle.
But...
Love the turrets though.
I mean, I do love love the turrets.
I love all the songs in Metal Gear.
They're all really good.
Can't wait to hear it.
Thank you.
I...
I put it together really, really quickly.
Because I was just like...
I was thinking.
I was like, oh no.
I don't have anything for April 30th this year.
Um...
Because, you know...
I'm not playing Metal Gear.
Solid 2.
And...
I already did the...
The skateboard game last year.
So I was like, what can I do?
And then I was like, wait, I can...
There's a...
There's a big spider!
Hold on.
I'm taking a picture of him.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I think that's the spider I saw before.
But he's even bigger!
There he goes.
Bye!
Where are you going?
He's climbing up!
Oh my god!
He's freaking out.
Why are you freaking out?
Is it because I'm freaking out?
Don't freak out.
Please don't freak out.
He's so big!
He's really big!
He's all the way to the ceiling!
He went on a training arc.
Okay, I'm gonna... What was I saying?
What was my story?
The cover?
Oh, yeah.
I came... I was like, Raid of Spiders.
No, I was not like that.
I did... I did... I'm not playing MGS2 and I did the skateboarding game already.
Sorry, I'm monitoring him.
I don't want him to go into my mid outfit.
Um...
And so I was like, what can I do for April 30th?
And then I was like, wait, I can do a cover of Can't Say Goodbye to Yesterday.
And... Oh, my God.
Now he's on the... Oh, my God.
Now he's on the ceiling ceiling.
Oh, my God.
If he falls... Don't fall.
Please don't fall.
So I came up with this idea probably, like, a week and a half ago.
And everybody... The mixer and the artist I pulled together, I was just like, Can you, like, rush this so fast?
And they were like, yeah.
And so it was awesome.
Charge that spider rent.
I wish.
Flamethrower?
Yeah, maybe.
I wish I had a devil arm right now.
So I could grabby grab them and then squash.
No!
Please, video games, become your life!
Press square to shoot it.
But, yeah.
So, yeah.
I came up with the idea pretty quickly.
So, sorry if I don't sound so great in it.
Because my voice has not been so great lately.
But, um...
And I made the video pretty quickly, too.
Go, kitty.
Go.
Pause.
Save Mito from spider.
She's not in here.
Oh, my gosh.
Please don't fall.
Oh, my God.
He's coming towards me.
Okay.
I gotta go.
I gotta go and take care of this.
What's the Mito, everybody?
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for our stream.
And helping me out.
And I will see you.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye!
Ah!
That's not what I meant to do.